[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo
the realm the realm what is going on
see y'all
happy sunday the lord's day
what up let me know how my levels is
going
to see some people in there oh man i see
lords of gaming.net
what's going on daniel mcgee on facebook
salute what up lord hold on hold on we
got
yo gee the legend we got my mans will be
hood gave me on the box y'all be good up
here yo good to see you brother hope
you're doing well
i get excited when i see you your memes
i know you still still rocking with us
gotta get you back in the room man it's
been a minute oh who else we got close
we got we got matt jimenez no doubt they
already calling for kings league and jp
we need king's knees god of war is
definitely
they own them
that's what i like
excited for the podcast
oh yeah i'm amazing here
[Music]
let me get a shout out i got you baby i
got you el nidi
zarcaster what's going on lydia max
what's up good to see you arcade what's
up good to see y'all got a good show for
the essence the lord got some fun got
some
giveaways oh ellie h
show i always put your last name show my
[ __ ] my man your cog happy lord's day
what's up man good to see you thank
y'all for being here early i don't even
shout y'all out enough i mean low shows
you know they don't do a mic check with
the host
gotta be in the chat early so i
appreciate y'all thanks a lot
and uh yeah we got some fun
you know what i'm saying
to the essence we're gonna be doing more
of just
iop show you know we made an internal
decision
and for my mental health because i got
so much going on
and then also as much as we love guests
so we're gonna have guests probably
gotta get the next week but like we're
gonna have more just iop just to kind of
take it back to the essence what got us
here and to be honest we have a lot of
fun
so salute to y'all for respecting that
and anybody that wants to be a guest
trust me y'all on the list we're going
to get around to it but
the lord's gotta get their mental health
right you know have fun we're all doing
a bunch of things and i'm saying outside
of this podcast
much respect
you got some fun in here king gonna be
coming through spoke the attic and
solving
we got a crazy show for you man i gotta
i gotta pull king up on charges
where's the pre-orders what's gonna
happen mostly
lydia madison thank you for that i love
just ilp shows so yeah a lot of people
tell us that i remember when we
started to blow with the guests and
people were like yo we love the guests
but sometimes when it's just y'all you
know what i mean
we're going to give y'all back to like
at least two at least minimum two no
guests about that's what we try to do
and uh we still gonna have some fire gas
though don't worry we're gonna have some
people which i need to put this back on
their name that's gonna come up
you know what i mean so
anyways
i will talk to y'all and hold on what is
with this thing
fortnite courses autism
says what's up chad all right man
i don't like what one day like that
either but there
anyway
good to see you
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
y'all messed up and turn me to an animal
and haters be swearing they real but
come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my
[Music]
you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting
[Music]
um
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
you could say that i'm very spoiled for
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
[Music]
to say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
you ain't got to say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
[Applause]
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back with messaging
people on
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line this is that
standard this is what we use right now
kind of our caffeine substitute and what
we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on deck number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to
advancedgg.com use code iron lord on the
checkout this is something i use all the
time got to support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
and watch them any snacks in the attic i
wanted to chill with the pack and be
like a young wolf but then they would
mistake me for attic if i can imagine
it's cool to give you some advice and
invite your girl to your squadron cause
if you don't give her that option you're
gonna be single player like siren you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be me
though i know it's my destiny words
incognito who cares if you fly if you're
still a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since a juvenile
i've been cursed with a curse to be
musical and if you hate it we'll meet in
the crucible wasn't it nothing it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do that it's doable if you got
work on a sunday it's suitable cause you
can listen to this in your cubicle on
the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
we live we live and direct hot mics and
all that but we got to make sure saab is
good you know says so i'll make sure
we're a little technical
hello oh there we go
sing the song sing this song
it's all for you
[Laughter]
we got to get him a record there
i mean not everybody obviously ricky
martin does his own thing or whatever
uh whenever we start hosting stuff
that's the opening it's all coming out
let's use it for that yeah yeah
here you go you monetized
costume malfunctioning
[Laughter]
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
the lords of gaming.net damn the super
chats are flying in love y'all damn hold
on yeah yeah they call they they flying
in episode number 263 this is another
glorious sunday we're back you want to
see me take king's knees oh my god we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date and today
we've got sony completing the
acquisition of budgie
microsoft and netflix partnership
playstation stars program and ps5 vrr
kings topic
king was so excited when he brought up
that topic yeah
i think it's like how he'd be
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming fresh off of that amazing stream
yesterday those original gaming nights
at the round table my co-host with the
cold mouse my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man lord addict of the
attic show how we doing sir i'm doing
pretty good you know i'm here to uh uh
i'm here rightfully to uh take king's
knees you know collect this collection
those knees till the game comes out but
this is this is the premature i'm taking
them
so we're going to wrap ups
them it's like those generic ones that
no one uses like it's like raven you're
using a raven you're using odin's ravens
these will never reach you king as long
as they get to me that's all that
matters the problem is you bust early
pause
don't take credit
for you
anyway what's going on what you've been
up to man
nothing we've uh we played that stream
yesterday shout out to like the 75
people that showed up yes it was a fun
stream yeah
we are going to be re
doing
the patreon and um you know and then
we'll be reflecting some of the members
stuff onto the patreon
so uh hopefully you guys enjoyed that
but uh you know we got a good show for
you guys today man we got a good show
for you guys
what's up that's what's up and of course
we have our most technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
softstradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the fall guy suit
my man lord sovereign how are we doing
that's right i i need to i need to
reimburse you guys
yeah you guys are standing out in front
of the check cash and place left knee
knuckles
like this
guy right here this guy is late with his
payments he's not seeing his instagram
timeline and he's spending money
you need to submit that you know in
writing oh man we got to get an expense
report dude
we got to have the receipts and
everything even though he was in the car
with us
yeah
it was fun yesterday man that was uh
i will say that i understand why
overcooked is it could be construed as a
stressful game
there's a hell of a stressful game
right there first that part wasn't even
stressful that's the funny part
yeah we didn't even get to the hard
stuff right
we left when it starts when the
restaurants up the greater they tears
yeah they started doing raids we're
doing raids in it i know right yeah my
my girl literally refuses to play that
game with me nah that's that's break up
material right there you're breaking up
that's it yes
you're gonna you're gonna curse somebody
out after uh you get a chance to see
when people are actual idiots
you looking for stuff and you're like
man i said where is
why is that an option
yeah why are you running around with hot
oil
anyway
shout out to the magic man gene because
uh yeah the fall guys is something
special that fall guys are special
um my niece and my nephew are going to
be over in the next couple of weeks so
i'm going to get a couple sessions in
with them i know they're going to enjoy
that nice
and what i've been up to
big papa gabe newell coming through baby
yeah steam deck yes
my lord loving him i'll tell you how yo
yo
um so
i would say if you're looking for for
games or certain games in general yeah
you don't necessarily have to go
into the steam store you can be found
other beans
okay okay okay okay that's what we do so
um
picked up some of them playstation games
that i had no chance in hell i'm gonna
be able to play in front of my
playstation so please just give us my
pieces
oh yeah uh
days gone
bro
bruh 60 60 oh
oh on the deck okay supported official
supporters no i believe it is verified
yeah okay it is it is okay
um
oh yeah so
uh you know i i'm i'm probably gonna
finish this game but what about what
about you don't i mean this is a thing
for me i'm not going to impose myself
but i'm just curious like so you don't
care about the trophies i'm done i'm
over that i have to be over there if i'm
going if this is going to be what it is
for me yeah i have to be over the trophy
stuff a second what we ain't never care
about no trouble we came from the days
where the cartridges was the cartridges
right when did we let that become
the one
that's on xbox
that was that that's the operative word
the platinum the platinum when the
platinum came into play i didn't care
until i got one yeah then i got my
golden shield
1886 i was like oh wait a minute this is
nice yeah cause you're like yo this is
my game
i don't have nobody
okay i don't have nobody over to the kid
to look at my stats and then the dudes
that do look up my stats and be like oh
you don't play anyway don't matter
because they don't know me like that
like you're right right right now pause
like that if you don't get off my
timeline with that you know i i just
woke up fresh and i got a i got a 3
million credit score
you was killing them both of those games
for someone that didn't play them
oh you know oh yeah but
you're on a whole different page
was like you played this game before i
checked it live i was like no he ate
like he only got three game three gamers
like
three yeah
you know the one that really did it for
me though
i got that god of war platinum and that
was like oh well i get it now
it starts the chain reaction i don't
look i don't care what pops up on the
screen actually i'll probably disable it
and say don't ever tell me what pop up
over here i really don't care about the
stuff that you're talking about but for
some reason and i guess it's because
where i hang out is my block on the xbox
the game is called mental like remember
me and mr high was going through
y'all created the game of school
competitions yeah yeah whose score was
higher you know it's it that was the
most bizarre thing that ever happened
the greatest what and me and kyle will
talk on the phone like you did you see
it how the hell let's go i got that way
yo he rented five games
king kong
the easy the easy one thousand
achievement game that's what people like
the devs really i was playing poker yeah
like you would play anything and you
could be like completely like 200
nhl games i forgot what's funny is i i
won't i won't say their name because i
don't know if they want to be out of
like that but someone was like i want to
get over 10 000 attic and i was like
well let's hit up smooth he knows all
those dumb games
yeah so so that's been it man but like
10 000 gamers score in 25 minutes no
doubt really wow that's ridiculous
that's insane
yeah so like i said that's continued to
be impressed by the steam deck no doubt
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
better than javier fartuna
him and ryan garcia
got it on last night shout to out to
everybody that came for combat talk yeah
um i got a chance to see a lot of the
new stuff that i implemented
um
shout out to my hell of a team in you
know uh graphic guards
dallas the man salute and drum stuff
um
it's it's
when you have a vision you have
something stuck in your head and you're
trying to project it to the world you
want to convey that um
that vision to the people that's helping
you to get into that space absolutely as
much as possible and
the team assembled
from every
minute aspect of what you see
understood the vision and executed the
assignment perfectly so
it's it's it's
absolutely insane and
the the biggest you know uh other
portion to that you know of course is
the iron lords and
of course it's you guys
because
every last one of you guys that super
chat that that shows up that retweets
and does all this stuff
that gives to the channel and the
channel gives back and we're able to to
fix stuff up like we're able to do
different things so when attic is able
to
do his uh his overlays on the attic show
and all this other stuff and all this
great stuff that we're able to bring to
you guys it's because you guys engage
with us and we we actually love that we
couldn't expand the shows unless you
guys yeah yeah honestly
really humble i had a real humbling
moment
after this stream yesterday that's so
humbling i forgot to end with the
intro outro
what have you been playing sir besides
the four guys had overcooked with us
that was bonkers yeah
four guys and overcooked that was
bonkers but um fortnite yes
okay
i'm i'ma stop this right now all these
games these season passes and i'm
holding i'm locked in because i spend my
my ten dollars whatever the hell i spend
now i must get everything i want out of
the season pass and every season pass
requires you to grind to some wild
extent oh i know in order to get the
last part out of it i've missed
butterfly wings and destiny because
myself was playing elden ring and it it
it's now it's like a marriage yes once
you make that commitment you're there
but now i'm committed to four different
women
the polygamous
battle pass lifestyle it's absolutely
nuts four guys i just got the new dlc
for outriders
uh destiny
and um
what's your fortnight
every time i sit down and and you gotta
think about it
three of these four 40s games
it's the same stuff it's not like a
story driven game where you're right and
then you out of here i play fortnite
it's a match after match after match and
it's repetitive same stuff that same
thing with destiny what which what are
you doing i'm doing salvathoon oh dudes
be like all right you doing seventh
through right i see where you at what
part you at you at the part with the
hopping and the thing and you like yeah
same stuff and i don't progress no place
and then i i look at my my list shout
out to phil dominus maxim is really
expensive
he put back the yakuza games for me yeah
bro you gotta play it it's kind of
interesting that that happened
yeah isn't it yeah isn't it soft is it
interesting i haven't i've never seen
[Laughter]
i'm doing all of them so you're doing
the action games first and then you
leave like a dragon for the air yeah i'm
i'm i'm doing all because he put him
right back in it was that sometimes
something happened and i was playing too
much of something or whatever
and i and he they was like yo they
leaving i'm like damn man they're
leaving but they back yeah and like uh
addict said i've never seen
a series come back like you know like a
game leave and it might be back in game
pass like a month or two later mm-hmm
don't be breeding up holes in our stores
all right
you know don't try to not agree with our
narrative
[Laughter]
well it was good
that's it that's it um you know so no
doubt yeah i got to get back to real
life and ending these games and stuff
because it changes you man you get stuck
into these little cycles
oh fighting the next dude
no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself what's up
yeah i was gonna say that that narco
game that that pokemon yeah we're gonna
get into it the shinobi himself laura
cognito spread that rule listen to the
roman iop not telling what you want to
hear what you need to hear shout out to
mr manny plays you had a good um
what you got to finally do just talk
about red force the uh the miranda
sanchez interview went in depth talking
about what else is going on in the as
far as xbox news and fun stuff um shout
out to the last word he bought this is
ty got travis holding me down they had
[ __ ] buff there um i wasn't able to be
there because i want to shout out the
call of duty esports league major so i
was uh kind of getting the lords trying
to get their little interests in this
esports thing shout out to lord justin
jacobson
had a tremendous time man cook he's
showing me what's going on in the
esports community it's funny because
it's like
this is some professional level stuff
like i clearly don't know anybody don't
know anything and like i
must call of duty you know you can tell
these dudes i don't know anybody and i'm
just sitting there biggling so that was
cool to see it was up in brooklyn new
york in the hometown salute to that make
any tournaments in the future i know who
to hit up let me hit up him yeah yeah
like yo hit me up with some people man i
want to be undefeated addict's team want
to come out on top need that hard carry
a backpack gang you know what i'm saying
but yeah they doing it really big the
esports community is growing and showing
the tremendous love also got to mingle
with a lot of people we met um king and
just passed um
you know either play nyc's or pax's
shout out to decoy games you know yeah i
know the pictures look nice yeah man
looks like he was having a good time
yeah
it looked like everybody there was
vaccinated though
huge is in your face like yeah so i'm
right now i'm playing
you're ridiculous like i'm looking at
the pictures
it was
speaking of launching shout out to um
revel
uh uh what is it a villa it's a
different type of tequila out right now
they're getting yeah they look like
they're moving and shaking it's very
very smooth i got a chance to oh they
gave me a
[Laughter]
so shout out to them shout out to decoy
games shout out to lady j watts we met
her at um play nyc she's coming up with
like all right not a dave and busters
but like a pure hardcore gamer space
gonna be in times square y'all
okay
it better be in the tourist spot because
yeah
yeah she's doing a thing we're going to
work on trying to get her on in the
future the ilp once that launched we got
to show some support for the city man
like it was
tremendous what she's doing man so
that's that as far as gaming um
as addicts said
listen man destiny look
you know you know we gotta open
relationships that's the name trouble
we gotta open really you know how it is
when the season is you know and i know
the clan is man i see y'all playing iron
banner grinder because i already did my
iron lord knight going back in there
until yeah
yeah i had somebody jump in my party and
say that stupidest attic you're about to
tell me yeah
this for you
i just need a break i did the story i'm
all caught up i got my iron lord tight i
got everything i really need outside of
maybe two or three weapons and stuff but
yeah no the rocket blade point is that
wave it's not even i was watching you
you you do it too much swinging from
roof to rooftop
like like bro like
i've never seen a a game like this like
it's it's a different take on battle
royale i didn't know how it was going to
work with the melee combat the swords
today it's battle royale that you forget
it's about royale you see the circle
feels like you're playing a quest game
an open world quest game right and they
got little missions on the map bounties
and things you could do while the battle
is going on and then they got the
mysticism of this like this this like
chinese dragon that's making that's
blowing the the thing to close the map
you know what's there from up top you
can see it it's like and then you can
fire your attic i heard that if all
three of us make it in trios and like
survive to win the battle up you get a
chance to fight the dragon i haven't
even seen that yet so it's got so many
secrets to it the mysticism is fire
the game is so crazy that i've never
seen you know most battle royales are
you know you it's just you land in the
map you find your weapons the season
pass
check sir we will not be expensing that
one
this is
if he would like to stream
because at some point in time it's
beneficial for his content right and the
reason why i say it's beneficial content
is because he's telling me a world for
stuff right now and having engagement
being pushed i saw the numbers i saw
another
is something called conflict of interest
when it comes to
him moving you moving the needle on you
i'm good but i want to shout out to game
pass this is a fantastic game
listen the learning curve is high what i
would highly advise hold on that's my
man um shout out javier mccain this pain
he he was in the chat with us rocking
and rolling it's fire shout out to
sinister you already know what it is all
right so this is what i recommend
because if you try to just jump in there
king you're gonna get
so what we did we added what you do is
just do the training right teach you the
basics do advanced training it's going
to give you like a simulation of how it
was with the um
battle royal but what i highly recommend
is do bot mode they got bot mode for the
joint and you get your confidence you
get to feel a higher before you go in
yeah it is crazy like it is so good that
they got a special event right now now
for attic or it's a four guys event you
run around looking for the little four
guys you're gonna say you grab them up
and you get special rewards but then
what happens is they put you in this pit
right
and it's like they just sold calum you
know how this edge is gonna fall off the
stage yeah right so in the pit it's
three verse three so they put all the
weapons all the hot armor in the middle
right so everybody start off with each
island and you race to get to the middle
right y'all fighting for the stuff now
what happens is as the game progresses
there's these big mallets that swing
right yeah and they start with one and
then it starts with multiple and you get
hit by it you get knocked off the map
that's the ko now you can keep coming
back in it's the person who get the most
kill so it gets so chaotic because
everybody's racing to the middle trying
to fight each other to get to get the
items of the thing but then you got to
avoid this these disasters and things
happening
it is so good yo shout out to the i
think it's 24 entertainment xbox did a
fantastic job during this game like i i
don't know how they found this game i
didn't know this game was never been on
pc before i mean i didn't know i didn't
even know they had an esports community
some of the best artists this is listen
destiny i'm on a little break to the new
season come out you know what i'm saying
the new season i did without the rocket
blade point where y'all gonna catch me
i'm just letting y'all know
what's going on the fact that it has
something to do with ninjas oh uh he's
definitely not it's channel five battle
royale gig you gonna look i can't wait
to play with you you are gonna
and i got the band to look like clouds
come down remember clouds come down
they got a straight up dude that looked
like jin sakai from sheba and he got
this demon spirit thing the chicks the
ninja chicks they look like jinx from gi
joe they got bro
the art design is fire they voice acting
skill trees individual moves everybody
got their own super this game is fi i'm
telling y'all acting like it ain't
nothing to play i'm telling y'all get
over there on gamepad download and try
and let me know holla back i brought uh
shaolin versus wu-tang
one and two
because they had toad in it
because toad this was single-handed him
and snake the single-handedly the best
dudes i had
told he got a special bone with that
yeah with the it's crazy
and
you're gonna love it you stupid you
could put your face in it
you can input your dudes are putting
phil spencer inside the game
you could get i'm telling y'all no
rocker blade point y'all sleeping this
is the battle royale right
um so we got some things we want to take
care of some little giveaways
yeah okay so
we got a few things to give away so
courtesy oh hold on a second let me let
me get this let me get this out yeah
407. we got to get the chance too
40 uh likes yeah
yeah yeah we got to get the super shout
out there live so far he said the rocket
blade point
crack the crate is good it's the truth
telling y'all man i'm telling you like
jim give it a shot the learning curve is
hard
give me your perspective because you
tried it for the first time
i i played games like that so i kind of
like i i picked up on it quick
uh but that would be you what kind of
two did with the dudes under the we
found that spot under the brick
we was the highway bandit king we was
hiding that thing the actual highway
bandit showed up and killed us
we found a spot that lead up a big
bridge that go over to ashalin temple
and there's a ravine with the river
underneath so we hide under the bridge
when the circle was closed we got the
spots
shows up and bam
like right on them and then you can rob
the bodies and do what i like is take
these stuff they think what i like to is
like what's cool is if you get knocked
out in the beginning of the game king
what's dope is they allow you to get you
got you go into a spirit form right if
you don't get revived then you go to a
spirit form and you gotta find it's like
all over the map these little spirit
revival temples
you get it one time right you could we
also find out that there's these special
items in the game that if you find them
you can revive your man back later if
one of your trios go down in the joint
i'm telling you anyway continue
let's say this i told you about to hit
this but i told them about this about
yeah we did that jake i know
okay y'all ready yes yes sir all right
so let me get these super chats first
then we get into this other business so
from the jump we got render five dollar
super chat sony has announced that
they're donating a portion of all
ragnarok pre-orders to king's gofundme
tim ryan is a good man have a great show
then we got face 23.
uh 20 dollars if we chat god of war
ragnarok got some xbox fans shook
harassing poor jeff about game awards
deadlines 2022 of the year the
playstation no worries you said they're
scared
listen man gotta walk outside gotta
watch do you have anything to say to
your brother and as the general of the
xbox art
i'm honestly gonna say that there is no
fear in us
you got to survive you got to bunker off
when in doubt just sit down and stick
your spare out pause
when in doubt just deny it out
that i couldn't bring you up on anything
until we saw at least pre-ordered yeah
that's it
let me talk one week later there's
pre-order
he's about to say now he does this to
himself every time
and i look at him and i'm like man he's
like bugs bunny you know he did he i
mean he's wildly coyote on god award
don't mean
every time so i told you last week and
this was my words can you pre-order it
right now he was like no what about next
week maybe i could do it next week i
said then talk to me next week when you
do it it's next week
right so what i did was i was allowed to
have you shut up for a whole week until
it went live you want to make it your
topic or whatever and i'm like good for
you
see
you got to be perfect every damn day
all i got to do is hit you this has
nothing to do with god yes no no sir all
i got to do is hit once so if they say
the day that it's supposed to come out
sorry you're not like oh right now
something the boat sink it's sorry it's
an unfortunate delay but he waiting for
that he's going to come out next week
and if it does happen the level of
snipers and the dudes just coming down
this this is turn my twitter off mute
the world and go to sleep day
i'm not worried about it you'll be in
trouble so basically what king is saying
is that in tune
but i already knew what he was going to
do but he was still going to get that
smoke
you'll smoke everybody last week you
told me
we got away from preorders
texas agrees uh with king he said for
spoken has been on pre-order since last
year and has been pushed back twice
don't bend the knee just yeah that's
cute
listen bro i i know i know king i know
king is the general in your army but i
don't mean you need to say well all i
can say is uh
attic uh wipe the back of your ears a
little wet would that be
he went behind the edge
i will say this
i would say this addict you you have to
you gotta make sure with king
that
he's not going to acquiesce until
there's no recourse yes until the game
is in his hands
and they know it because and they've
seen it they've seen me wiggle away i'm
james bond
oh so so
just to clarify you are stating that you
like wiggling your way out of situations
i'm staying in that yo you gonna run out
of bullets and if you miss on god you're
in trouble
i've already hit you twice though once i
come out of that coffin and the hand
come up like the undertaker
yo you know what's funny right now king
k king looked like he just played an
entire movie at die hard you got bruises
right now you just spirit ball me you
walking out the room and the lights went
out and you heard
fury
all right what else we got here we got a
jd gamer 50 super chat uh good morning
lords and ladies let's start this day
off right hit that like button folks
with that said i'm less interested in
sony completing the acquisition of
bungie and more interested to see how
they break up in a couple of years oh
you're gonna like the poll question
we'll see we'll see
tony bright remember for 24 months thank
you brother
happy to be here live here for king's
accurate prediction of the imminent sony
bundy break up in a couple of years
it's a different conversation
as always great time to be a gamer yes
it is so yes it is
then we have render two dollars of a
chat saab starting a new r b group
called lords to man
[Laughter]
is out of control
then we got otaku five dollar super chat
where's my bayonetta three topic we why
are we not talking about game of the
year
bayonetta 3.
i just oh
it's oh it looked good but it looked
good
it looked nintendo switch good like
if bayonetta had the wings to be on xbox
a playstation as well that you know it
would it would look prettier
and speaking of something look at her
outfit it changed
more clothes
and i said as soon as they went
exclusive to nintendo nintendo gave them
a list of demands more than likely it
was like i don't know
no no you know what it is you know what
it is though right you know what it is
there's a um because there's plenty of
there's plenty of not safe for work
stuff on top yeah so
they
they have a setting in the game
they have a setting in the game where
you could have
less not safe for work stuff okay oh
okay okay that's probably what they're
showing nintendo
yeah
i was gonna say you know in the times we
live in too i think that would have to
do more with the nintendo because
nintendo's left some pretty scandalous
stuff on their platform
they got this
just sitting there i'm waiting for
brother too listen if you if you were to
scour that e-shop oh my love this stuff
i mean this stuff they this nintendo
station
playstation since there's more than
nintendo yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
true
they got something a little bit more
relaxing than power washers
i'm sure for some sections of the
community there's plenty of this place
to go
there we got dingo mcficken 20 super
chat wait
someone said jim ryan's a good man
uh waiter i'll have what he's having
funny how the narrative was why would
sony follow the model of a third place
company yet here we are with another
copy ps points now
that's right yeah
hey man if it works if it works you know
the imitation is the the the what is the
the serious form of flattering lottery
and jim ryan is flattering the hell out
of
consider considering they did that
playstation stars thing we'll talk about
later
[Music]
we got heart key
ten
salute to the lords on this fine sunday
warner or netflix decisions decisions
good to see playstation is wrecking yeah
we're gonna we're gonna talk about that
we get to that good to see playstation
is recognizing their loyal fan base with
rewards if only other consoles had
something like that yes
bro even the nintendo even nintendo
everything you buy in that eshop gets
you gold points to buy other stuff yep
jd gamer 20 super chat
on a side note if microsoft ends up
acquiring netflix and i think they will
for around 120 billion it's over for
sony in so many ways and expect them to
get spotify after that
so can someone explain to me how buying
the uh netflix is like going to hurt
like help microsoft with xbox let's say
let's say let's save it for the let's
say we got bars we got boss yeah we got
let's say for the topic trust me i know
where you're going
i mean if yeah if you look at the
current thing that they're we're doing
together that's why
this is a lot of money
those two purchases make microsoft an
entertainment juggernaut yep
then we got hardware
super chat start with yakuza 0 if you
want to play through the through them
king that's true go back to that's what
i'm doing although it's hard to go to
kiwami one and two after zero because
zero is a newer game but they're still
great it took getting through the first
boss fight for me to get into it the
series is good yes it is very much so
don't know taku five dollar super chat
play the alpha for creative assembly's
new fps aesthetically it's meh but
gameplay-wise it has so much potential i
had a lot of fun with it
then we got down to taco again
it's called hyenas that that's the sega
game right isn't it yeah
and otaku you ain't supposed to be
talking about that by the way
just so you know someone
the fans is watching careful bro careful
forgot to add that
there we go clutch man 20 super chat i
cringe when i hear slow news week when
sometimes we just want to hear from the
devs and their experiences more content
creators should reach out to them you
guys here at iop always do a great job
with that keep it up yes we have to put
a spotlight on the people that make the
things that we love absolutely
absolutely absolutely more coming yeah
for sure
then we got boondy two dollars super
chat why go on i'll be enough respect
no you don't
know go
stitch two dollar super chat play with
my joystick should write a song for
savvy to sing please
wow
i'll make a thousand dollar patreons
here for that
i'm gonna tell you right now do not put
anything that you think that is out of
reach oh yeah they will reach it and
grab it oh no no like i said i am
willing to subject myself to that why
don't you subject yourself to a hot chip
challenge why don't you do that because
you know what you know what i please
guys
no i'm not doing that so i can help my
wife we chose our stuff you're the one
that chose crazy stuff no i throw stuff
that i thought people would not go to
you know what you understand like please
girl shout out to wilmington i love that
guy let me tell you something will be
you have mark you have marked me you you
have yeah i've been in therapy because
of you sir
because of you you had a whole
conversation about what will did to me
he's like what the hell show me on the
teddy bear
i said he did
things happen to me
you know he said he said he said show me
on the teddy bear uh we'll touch that i
can't show you the teddy bear listen
[ __ ] but this this tattoo oh
i'm done
it's great to see him getting his
strengths back up so yeah it's wonderful
to see
oh let me see what else what we have
next up we got big cloud gaming member
for 17 months smash that like button
folks thank you sir
shout out to big clown just came off a
fantastic interview with david jaffe you
know what i'm saying he's been killing
it in the game shot lords of gaming.net
big cloud gaming and he outside doing a
little article day ig you're getting
idea in love he outside moving
maybe and maybe he'll be there'll be
some announcements
this guy has a great feature i don't
know this guy is it's amazing
yeah i like that i like that
rockefeller
there we have it
fifty dollars if we check king if you're
so confident put your eyebrows on the
line
this dude here who are you
do you put your face out put your face
in there i wasn't tall
okay
put your face out man stop talking to me
about that put your eyebrows in the mix
you're out there talking oh you capping
he's yeah king i can't wait
um
it's literally went down like five times
what was it
yeah zoom i don't know i don't know why
but i have such a hard time with zoom it
shuts down all the time it's so weird
yeah
i'll be back all right no doubt you guys
should jump right in
we got jeez two dollars of a chap this
isn't phillip todd sony actually
delivers oh
[Music]
okay okay
then we got lord meyerhoff
with the hundred thousand i think it's
it's called indonesian rupees okay
shout out to you sir thank you brothers
i love playstation stars more than
microsoft rewards because it is
officially supported on my country
rather than ms rewards can someone ask
microsoft when they expand services to
other countries that's huge that's right
that's right
they've got to improve on a global level
we're talking about localization we talk
about rewards i could talk about with
that
we go we listen that's a good point
where where's the brother from where's
the lord from indonesia indonesia
what listen we do know you know a lot of
executives do listen to ireland's
podcast we'll put it out there to get
you get some love to that to your
country man
yeah that's i mean again you're gonna
rep the ones that kind of are there for
you so for sure yes absolutely and we
got donald taco two dollars super chat
as cog would say we outside we outside
let's go let's go shout out to bok boom
i agree microsoft uh rewards needs to
expand yeah man that's my brother too
yeah for sure
definitely for purchases give me some
money for purchasing games thank you
very much absolutely then we got
masochista two dollars masochists two
dollars
oh look my favorite xbox podcast is on
now
hey thanks for showing up again
hey hey
with your favorite xbox host lord king
david yes shout out to everybody that's
hypnotized by the words that's coming
out of mommy yeah they clearly
everything
it's like everything they take it's his
yeah yeah he's been indoctrinated into
the world of xbox face forward please
no doubt all right that's it on super
chat so we have so uh [ __ ] i want you to
set it up
what is what is this amazing giveaway
that we have look you already know
advanced gg ggs in the building you got
to get that fresh powder you know what
i'm saying gaming powder you know how we
do so we got that focus line obviously
you know what i'm saying got the focus
and that that'll get you almost like
your coffee substitute right you you
know what i'm saying you're playing long
you're going to do a long gaming session
or you're at work and you don't watch
that little bump today
you know
yeah we're going to do the overcooked
stream hit that two scoops 16 ounces of
water and if you want two scoops yeah
you'll be sleeping like by wednesday you
might fall asleep
but i'll be productive you'll be
productive with the focus you know what
i'm saying so i would say for your first
time bro you you do to the game one
scoop eight ounces that'll be enough
powder for you to get through right oh
and then you know you build your
tolerance up taking that stir shake it
not stirred brothers all that stuff you
know what i'm saying
then you know what i'm saying but if you
want to go to the gym
you know what i'm saying okay and you
only want a little pre-workout
substitute we got that that's what i
mean man yeah we got that energy line
you know what i'm saying the energy
level sometimes i'll be feeling you know
like a days ago
and i'll be needing something to boost
some something to take me to the next
level exactly you do that joint right
before you know what i mean okay again
one scoop too like like how how how how
how long before i start my actual
workout half an hour or 20 minutes 30
minutes before you got to
after that you know but then i got my
brothers they'd be like you know what
i'm saying like you know what i got the
sugar thing i can't do i can't take
sugar or you know what i can yeah what
about you what if i'm pre-diabetic bro
yeah you diabetic you know what i'm
saying we got that hydration line for
you right oh you know what i'm saying so
the hydration basically it comes in that
that camouflage color that yeah we got
it's the lemonade it's the lemonade
you know what i'm saying but this is the
no sugar you know what i'm saying and um
no caffeine so think about get your
electrolytes you know what i'm saying so
it's like gatorade without the sugar
right so for those people you can't do
the water you know what i'm saying you
want to do something hydration yeah you
wanna be feeling depleted exactly you
know what i'm saying so shout out to the
good folks of advanced gg we out here
advanced gang moving that powder very
well get this stuff yeah so we got you
know what we got we got something just
for you and the people right man i've
come together we're gonna do this
giveaway starter pack you know what i'm
saying so we're gonna give six lucky
winners today in the realm you know that
advanced gg somebody said roll it roll
it right
it is to the members just to clarify
okay um i do think that to give people
time if they do want to sign up to
remember we should give half away now
and half away later yeah that's fine
that's fine yeah yeah okay so we'll do
three now
we got six to give away today yeah yeah
good good good quarter
how are we moving around here i like how
you move
let's go we got to go
imagine if like
they didn't come in like the containers
they come in they come in like these
containers and it would give us a bag
put that to the screen which one what
powder is that sir
oh you got that sour yeah
[Applause]
why does it look like the guy on the
cover is you yeah
put the shower up real quick move it to
the side just because he got a beard and
he stopped
out of pocket give him the
[Laughter]
hydration we got that lemonade hydration
my camera's bugging right now but this
is the lemonade hydration yeah that's
the camouflage version yeah
again for anybody who wanted to even try
and buy without the thing that don't
that don't win the game twenty percent
off y'all advanced gg.com use code iron
lord on the checkout make sure you do
that core island so go to advanced
gg.com cold on get 20 it goes out monday
at uh what you call what 1 p.m eastern
so you got a little time
to get the product in the kitchen
whatever would you chef it up
[Music]
i need you to set up shop in west
virginia we try to move the operation to
west virginia now
first off we do enough stuff up here
[Applause]
label and it's just a white box and they
open what is that
dude in the back yellow powder
don't let the spot get raining don't let
the spiders
what i do is i record cogs saying drop
that powder and he's like what is this
what is it
anyway so we got three lucky winners
right that's what we're doing yeah so
we're gonna do up front we're gonna do
let's do this
okay powder on one second oh before i
get into that let me get this one last
one
can't wait for microsoft to buy sony
like vince mcmahon wcw then phil shows
up on a state of play and says you're
fine
you know
saturday night raw let's go
all right so now let's jump into this
now okay so the winner
okay our first advanced gg giveaway
we're getting that powder
tj scotch tj scott congratulations
em up put it tj
the bag bag it up ship it nice to him
exactly you guys i'm i have a link for
you guys you can go in
uh you have to you have to set up an
account yes but again this initial stuff
is free so
okay so how he got it how are you going
to get the date you gonna give me
instructions on twitter
if you have a twitter account it should
be here i'm looking at all of our
patreon he said tj not dj oro stop it
that's not for you you already got your
powder relax
okay so everybody on uh patreon i have
their email at the very least so okay
but if there is i'll check if you guys
if you are on twitter then i will just
dm you the information no doubt that
what else the interesting part now is i
don't know if it works because i've
never done it but you can actually gift
memberships now so
i've never i've only seen it done on
like one or two podcasts i've not
actually seen it myself but
you can actually get memberships now so
like shout out to youtube for stealing
stuff from twitch like years after
israel
all right and our second uh advanced gg
giveaway goes
get to verse powder
kool-aid 117.
he need it he mix it baby mix it mix
that thing mix that up kool-aid 117.
shout out to you sir let's go all right
and then our third and final giveaway
for right now
starter kits powder
goes to
[Music]
salsa oh that's the perfect person
that's the perfect person to get
advantages
shout out to the winners again i will
get at you guys either by evia email or
if you guys have a
twitter handles i will get at you in dms
on twitter and give you your information
no doubt suits everybody you already
know what vsdg and once again exactly if
anybody wants to sign up
sign up to the patreon during the course
of the show and then you will have the
opportunity to jump in and get this
later on in the show i guess we'll do it
right before the end yeah yes sir
no doubt all right he said they cut the
powder with the kool-aid
[Laughter]
anyway so oh yeah we got this oh get
their own little avatar to bust through
walls
i can't shout out to the witness we're
gonna do a lot more of these giveaways
put the powder out there the streets
removing the shaking but um anyway last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken with the latest news
regarding halo infinite lower engagement
numbers on steam as a free to play title
what do you think is the quickest way to
get halo infinite back on track the
winner of the three-way iop poll with a
commanding 62
of the vote was make a major internal
shakeup at 343 to help produce halo
content and fix bugs in a timely fashion
group
coming in at second percent at 20
percent of the vote was the messi lords
i don't care they need to keep
monetizing the master chief collection
since the majority of the community is
only playing that anyway
and that last place at 12 of the vote
was removed 343 completely from
ownership of the halo franchise it's
time for a fresh start group shout out
to all the lords who participated in the
poll lord king you seem to have some
thoughts about this what the people felt
uh it's
regardless to what all of it was like
negative 2 3 4 3.
so the consensus is you know get the
content up get that out to the people i
agree with that um i think you know guys
have a pigeon memory when it comes to
stuff you know when it comes to video
games they can talk about one thing for
months and then when they actually get
what they're looking for like you know
they quelled and they quiet yeah until
you know they need some more stuff to
digest so they just got to get a proper
cadence and you know release stuff out
on a timely fashion i give 343 the
benefit of the doubt knowing all the
stuff that they went through to get to
the point where they act so i just think
they uh underestimated the the
assignment to be honest with you mm-hmm
interesting best facts interesting so uh
i think we got one more channel we got
two more super chat we heading to the
topics we got donald taco five dollar
super chat i heard g-fuel maddie been
moving in on your turn oh no that's
what's going on
let me know if y'all need some muscle to
go handle any uh situation
this is a mob situation on powder maddy
is the homie you know what i'm saying
and we over here pumping on our block
with our powder and he over there and we
have we had to sit down and there's
rules the engagement with what he doing
but this is an advanced gg block this is
what we do over here shout out to my
homie though we got which respects like
the mafia we you know
territories if he oversteps
you know we have measures set in place
me and king
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
duke brother we had to talk about it man
that's slow i mean that's what bosses do
when they respect your block but stay
the hell off the body if you heard me
moving that's what bosses do when they
move in different gaming powder that's
what they do
i respect your husband
[Laughter]
did that thing go smooth yesterday or
saw buying that thing yep oh yeah we
have it it is now
i they did tell me it would not be day
and date
that's what they did tell me so
we do have a giveaway we're gonna do on
twitter uh it's gonna be for a god of
war collectors edition
that goes with my
to make it even worse
they did get a whole sign sale deliver
cradles face for me
[Laughter]
you know we decided that you know we
never really uh do anything on twitter
so we want to pick up our presents in
there a little bit
uh so keep look on that we uh like cuss
off said it won't be dane day
unfortunately i needed i mean either way
it wouldn't be day and date because even
if it gets to me day and date i have to
reship it to the winner so yeah who
would it be
and i got to get over there i got a sign
that says hey it's my knees
can't win attic you know
he needs a patreon for the god of war
collection edition collector's edition
he said i got nothing to do with me
he's already looking at the picture
we are redoing how that patreon looks
you know
get out of here
the wrong blocks
like no it's not
yeah move up your bike just a tad you're
like you're a little low i don't know if
you should fall away or you know what
you call it just upper tail he's on the
golden gate bridge
yeah that's what he over there
every time people tell me that i end up
being too loud like now you're good now
it's perfect that's perfect perfect oh
shout out to gabe will be he said you
know i love all of your brothers
so happy to see you yes you know what
you've been going through and every time
i see your super chat i'm not even super
chat whatever i see just you on twitter
whatever just moving and shaking and
putting up memes
i'm like all right yes all right
because he's getting there he's getting
absolutely so don't worry about none of
that other stuff that is super
challenging
that
me as a person in the industry can't
share but i like yeah i gotta secretly
like from the distance
i'm down with all of them i only like
and retweet certain ones
your man is here he said can we get a
giveaway for a game coming out in 2022
let me play with your joystick what do
you think what game is coming out
that go on another website
this man is just alluding to the fact
that he doesn't believe ragnaros is
coming out i don't know what they're
talking about
okay
they're going left with this
conversation definitely like that's what
he's saying okay
okay we got one more super chat before
we move on we got lord way hick e-i-c-o
of the lords of gabriel.net mock move
five-dollar super chat addicts should
have known to insert show me your build
clause when he entered a bethany
he's gonna do is if he loses that it's
just clown on god of war and try to keep
it moving that's what he said well i
mean i i actually could talk about i
know why they could probably hit that
date mm-hmm yeah
oh here we go
here we go
last generation game up to snuff on that
new hardware ready
was able to get the jolt in our audition
cost him 287 bro
you can go to ebay and get triple that
right now listen he's sick in the head
just for some dice and a rubber
hammer not gonna happen that could
happen no give me the digit get out of
here i know how much people aren't gonna
like to hear this but i i feel like
until they find a way to combat
these
these bots that are buying these for
scalpers and stuff they need to do just
in in store like because at this point
literally
oh my god sorry this is a chat super
chat
like the majority like 80 of the of the
purchases on this on these type of
online features and online products
are coming from sculptors and they're
selling the other 20 for like five times
the amount oh i'll show you yeah for
sure uh-huh
so we've got some channels i think we're
done with superstars
especially super chat for you let me
play with your joystick five thousand
chat i need to see saab's 2022 build
gotta make sure it's uh
coming on time
[Music]
[Music]
completing the acquisition is bungie's
now officially part of saudi playstation
made the announcement the agreement on
their twitter account agreement acquired
bungie has closed so now we can
officially say welcome to the
playstation family the acquisition after
that announcement the deal was worth 3.6
billion but on an sec filing on friday
it was said the deal was approximately
3.7 billion so now that they're under
the umbrella bungie will continue to
independently publish and creatively
develop our games
bungie ceo pete parsons said in the blog
post and future games in development
won't be playstation exclusives bungie's
joe blackburn and justin truman said but
sony does plan to lean on bungie for its
world-class expertise in multi-platform
development and live game survives keep
laughing live game services which will
help us deliver in our vision of
expanding playstation to hundreds of
millions of gamers say ceo jim ryan
live service games as a critical part of
playstation future as it plans to launch
more than 10
new live service games by march of 2026
so the deal is done y'all splunky as
part of the playstation family i wanted
to bring this to the realm y'all like
what are y'all thinking how are you
feeling long-term uh parts of the
acquisition short term and just overall
so lord attic man where you're at now
that the deal is complete why did you
just play station studio
it is what it is as long as they keep
they uh
pause
come to the mic or your time i'm
literally right next to the mic but you
put your lips on it please wow
i'm literally right he's not great now
you sound great there you go there you
go when it's on your lips
of course no good man
when it comes to bungie it's just like
you know
i don't think nothing necessarily
changes i'd be surprised if like
something with matter changes
but i don't think destiny i don't think
they're going to like pop in there and
be like we're taking all the destiny off
of uh off of xbox but i'm curious what
happens with matter
yeah cause you still i was gonna ask you
because you still felt a little even
though they're saying
multi-platform games i remember your
thing is you want to see when a new iep
drops right if if matter will steal it's
not even it's not even a matter of
ips like
if if matter comes on all multiplied so
they gonna try to do some dlc stuff that
they did with destiny and have like a
massive amount of the game restricted
from xbox like right
like i just got to see it i know that
you know it's all 100 up the bungee
but is sony going to eventually corrupt
bungie after a long amount of time too
so it's just like
and that corrupts probably a really
strong word for that it's just like look
obviously you're going to want to do
stuff that benefits your company and if
sony's in for your company more than
it's hurting your company
then are their logistics going to change
on what they want for the future of
their company so i i just got to see
more time with the with them actually
owning bungie okay fair enough lord sav
the bungie is part of playstation
studios how we feeling about the
acquisition now it's complete yeah i
mean
it has begun we'll see we're going to
really see what what this means i think
i think attic hit it on the nose i think
you know
for as much autonomy as they're supposed
to have
i think this right if obviously bungie's
ip destiny is going to do great whatever
the next ip is probably you know they
they they're the ones who have the
expertise in this area
obviously their help
and expertise is going to allow these
other games to hopefully flourish in the
way that sony wants but again when
you're talking about creating all these
service-based games
something's going to fail guaranteed not
everything's going to hit something's
going to fail
so the question is uh so do you guys
think it's possible that sony
now since bungie's properly funded sony
might actually like really say yo
you know we know that you didn't want to
do a destiny 3 maybe for a lot of
financial reasons but if we fully back
this do you think that might come out on
playstation only i mean no playstation
only i don't think anything that has
anything to do that that requires a
large player base
it doesn't make any sense for it to be
exclusive
yeah man it's it's not i don't it
doesn't make any sense anymore and i
think sony's sony's over that hurdle
right they're over that hurdle when it
comes to the wall garden they're still
in there when it comes to their single
player first party stuff but when it
comes to this i think they really do
understand that you gotta have as much
people playing that day one as possible
especially live services especially
online population yeah so i mean
the the
the bungie stuff when it comes to
multi-plat yeah i mean the expectations
will be on xbox but everything else
i think you're talking pc playstation
oh so you think you think you think it's
not going to be multi-player you think
xbox will be not part of some of these
games i think
if bungie advocates across the board
really not even the next bungee ip
no i i i think that
matter is different but it's like i said
matter was
in works and matter was with the
budgeting that bungie currently had
that's completely different now
like
can literally make any game they want
now because arguably bungie is sony's
best studio they have right now
like you know sure god of war all that
that's amazing but bungie probably makes
more money than all those games combined
oh he's talking about from a financial
standpoint financially
that's all these companies care about
some financial aspects so so with that
saying with that said if they have that
sort of leverage and pull
they could advocate for other games that
maybe sony just expected to have in
their ecosystem plus the pc and be like
yo this needs to be everywhere i mean if
you really want this to pop you really
need to open the floodgates
um and that's a possibility so
when it comes to bungee's influence on
place potential influence on playstation
the the ramifications are huge because
if they hit with matter and they hit
with helping these other games come to
fruition and come to light and really be
successful and make the money hand over
fists
bungee's leverage is going to be sort of
uh what should we call it a um
a respawn situation within ea whereas
like
you know the leverage is there for them
to kind of do whatever the hell they
want
and i think
on the bungee side it really to me
the sky is the limit now the question
here remains is this
if not all of those things hit in the
way that playstation wants the jim ryan
wants them to hit talk about long-term
ramifications long-term ramifications
then i could pretend i could potentially
see what we were joking about before the
fact that you know bungie can't stay
married very long oh you're gonna like
i could see that happen and another
thing is like
there is
a negative
uh
a negative point that this
that this bungie acquisition can get
because the bungie
talks to all these developers and stuff
and they really help fine-tune a lot of
these free-to-play games
and a lot of the let's let's not even
say let's say
half of them do good but half of them
are making
similar not all not type of destiny
money but they're making good money how
long is it before sony's like
yo god award them cute
but the these free-to-play games are
bringing us in billions a year he said
he wants
and then 10 service
let's say five of them do well and
they're bringing in billions each a year
then
is sony gonna start like not necessarily
not supporting these games anymore but
you know they're like look like you know
you we used to give you five years but
now we got to give you three because
these these freedom plays are outshining
you at every corner financially i mean
that is that is the worry right because
my my thing my thinking is okay if these
free to plays are making you this much
money that's all the more money that can
go into making quality single-player
products the stuff that the playstation
fan base is used to getting right um but
but it costs a lot of money to fund
these things that is true
and jim was on record for saying as king
amply puts like it's not enough he's not
happy
with
you know it's he feels console gaming is
in his niche he feels that like they
should be like his games are should be
way bigger than you know the 10 million
whatever it is that they're selling now
well yeah speaking of 10 million
uh
last of us too is only sold around about
10 million think about that last of us
part two
i mean it's still
i don't want to minimize that that is
impressive right but fr if you look at
that big corporate right and they're
looking at the comparative the player
base yeah
going to say yo that's great but we got
you know 150 million playstation 4's out
there right so like what can we get
that's going to get into that let's be
honest like a lot of these companies
they want that call of duty they want
that fortnite they want they want
to me sony seems like they want their
own
right yeah so now it's like okay we got
one of these we gonna get this hand over
fist underneath our house so it'll be
interesting like what you're saying if
the philosophy to what attica said if
the philosophy shifts and they hit with
with some of these live service games
yeah because you would think you would
think all the money in the world allows
you to do more stuff with the here's the
thing but the thinking changes right
well it's it's not necessarily all the
money in the world you start looking at
what brings you money money yeah and
it's just like i don't think they'll
ever go away from single-player games
but how they've always been so open with
you know gorilla making newer stuff you
know they're gonna be like look
what you're talking about is cool
but we're making all this money like
this these studios these ten five six
seven i don't know how many is going to
succeed right they're literally funding
the whole company right now
your studios are bringing in good money
and let's be real uh with your games we
got to split with people because free to
play you only got to split with this and
to your product we gotta let ken get his
balls off but to your point at it it is
interesting that bungie has all this
preferential treatment to kind of move
in the way
let's be honest like the the rest
of the playstation studios that have
been recently acquired have been known
to make only playstation exclusive
content this is the first time i'm
seeing that it's like you're off the rep
no no we still multiply we still doing
what we want to do it's very interesting
about that aspect but i'm let's often
this is boss
um i mean and i go all the way back to
sean layton once again when he talked
about the the
how this is not sustainable to make this
level game so you talk about how the
thinking could shift
when they're making this money if they
make this money um you know
it's theoretical we don't know it is it
is think about it
you know
if all these games
if they all flop then there's a problem
that's a big problem
um but you think about it like are we
getting you know
is the fan base going to accept a 10
hour
super
polished whatever they get that's what
you're saying
70 and 80 bucks all i'm saying is the
center of their tutsi role right now is
single-player games right but if that
shifts and it becomes free to play games
as a service type games
then you're going to probably have a
sony that's like what can we do with
this to make it more
yeah
yeah and then look and the last thing
i'll say is just
this in this is indicative of a real
overarching shift for sony's
for sony period um
this is the biggest shift we've seen
from them in quite some time
and really
no it's an attempt to do it whether they
succeed or not
the fact of the matter is that jim's
trying to make this money and this is
how the guy has really been cast
so this is the thing i don't it's scary
because
you know playstation very scary for who
is it scary for the people that want
playstation to be a certain thing and
stay a certain way wait you're being
negates not on other platforms
and not the single player hashtag just
ones that cost exactly so are you
implying that this the hashtag just my
hashtag just wasn't in danger
to get it in danger but it is they're in
danger wouldn't be the focus yeah i do
think that
at the moment it's like you have that
really
nice restaurant in your place it's it's
it's a nice restaurant and they only had
that they focus on steak it's that steak
yeah that's the only thing they do and
then they franchise it and then they
franchise it out but but they start
bringing in seafood and the seafood's
making more money so it's just like
when all the dynamic and all the power
shifts to one brand
what is that original brand leader
nobody cares about mama mia no more do
we continue to fund this brand the way
it's been doing when it's not
realistically bringing in the money that
this other one i got after the kid goes
a lot more money to the other i got it
i actually before kingdom because i know
he gonna get his boss yeah
the suggest i know y'all going right and
i see you i know and it's gonna be a
shock to a lot of people if it goes that
way because there's a very there's
potential that it could go what addict
is saying right if they see this money
and the live server is hitting it's like
yo it's a goal and they know the single
player is what they do but they're
looking at what's bringing in the most
right so i got you right after that what
i'm going to say is
like the thing that i think that we
could forget that that could happen is
look at my beloved goes to toshiba right
look at how they have a multiplayer
legends mode which is like a destiny
raid cooperative kind of experience
let's just say they use bungie as that
like
outsourcing for multi-player components
of their single player games so now you
add or like think about last of us has
faction modes right you could have that
add-on mode that bungie could be
outsourcing to add that extra because
because jim is like look the just ones
are great but let's be honest they want
even more
the 10 but are you saying that bungie
themselves will handle these multiplayer
components
i think they might oversee some of it to
see if certain like i think they kind of
strictly they like people are like all
attic you're wrong on this they didn't
spend 2.5 billion dollars for nothing
right they spin it because they do see
their company in some way shape shift
going this direction
yeah no it's this one
we gotta get something we gotta get
kickers
i got a good analogy right now that
we're having right now what's up from
software has always been very key on
what their folder is what type of games
they make but after the success of eldon
ring you got a lot of from software fans
nervous on if they're going to try to
casualize right good point good point
they did it they had the most success
they've ever seen good point they had
the most success they've they didn't
even expect elderly to do what it's
doing
they're going to be microchan
listen man we're talking about time to
get tardis we're talking about changing
the structure that that from software
builds it's games on oh
they changed it even a little bit they
made it more open world they made it
more
accessible to other people they didn't
keep you stuck on a boss over and over
again you can leave those bosses they
did these to make their game more sense
we'll see maybe they maybe the test bed
is armored core and we'll see if they
add something to the armboard core then
that's monetary but so i've got your
boss's kid got it i know he could cook
it yeah all right let's let king let's
get kicked out we got kid interrupted
king so what you dick man sony the
acquisition is complete bungie's part of
playstation studios what is your feeling
on this
this is like a celebrity marriage you
know they they're walking out they just
said they vows they just got married
they was like
and now pronounce you man and wife
and you may kiss the bride and they kiss
and then she step back and be like um
first off first order
it wasn't 3 billion it was 3.7
it was 3.7 billion
uh so uh respect on the ring in the
contract and i'm still
for the
streets i want y'all to know
everything that i'm doing now
and anything that i'm doing in the
future
is for the street
right honey
as soon as they got to cut the cake he's
like yes
um i love her for her brains
and her business know-how
and i i can't constrain her and hold her
back her creative genius can be spread
to the world and it's it's upon
this principle our relationship will
stand
is that is that what you wanted me to
say love
is that what you want to be
you did good now sit down
uh because we have more business to
attend oh my god and that's that's
exactly how it went yo dirk griggity
laughing at the check
when you do just talking about um oh i
think matter matter is going to be
everywhere
all right
anything that she does is for the
streets
all right you don't ever start a
relationship off with remember what you
said
okay
women that's the freedom that was the
point we talked about they gave the out
right there yeah
jim ryan says well i would like for you
to uh put this one game around and only
in this
i told you on the day we said yes
it's a prenup in the if you act up in
anything
i'ma terminate this because it is
nothing to take this off honestly you
got tasks laughing on that chat
um
i wonder
what type of
hoops they would have to jump through to
separate themselves from something
there's no no no
no
mergers and acquisitions he has never
seen a contract that has given so much
power to the studio to be able to
purchase it being purchased to be able
to kind of do
what they want so i would be surprised
based on how this contract is structured
that they don't have protections if it
goes left
there's no hope hulk said this is he
yeah he said it in the most
nicest corporate ways off
i don't know why saudi allowed this to
happen like he basically said i know why
if it is truly a hundred percent there's
nothing sony can do to intervene with
bungie
then it's like at that point they're
literally just going to be
they bought them to make sure microsoft
never got their hands on them well and
they bought them to make sure that they
can help them fund their
uh start their their giant corporations
y'all are missing the forest for the
trees
they purchase them because they're in
business with what they're talking about
they they look at bungie they see how
successful it is in the space that they
are deficient
and no they want to be that space that's
single player stuff actually that was an
indictment on you guys in the console
dudes that single player it's not enough
stuff was an indictment on you guys all
you guys talking about oh you know sony
is known for the single player in the
corner banger that talks to only 10 of
your audience and that's why it's only
getting 10 million and it's not going
higher and dudes is frustrated with you
right they're frustrated with the fact
that the level of engagement is not
happening
and i told you all before when the
acquisition was going down
that sony is for the streets jim ryan
told you he wants 10 games of service
games available this is where he's going
he didn't tell you you know what we're
going to do is do the last of us part
three and it's only going to be a single
player
driven game he did say blockbusters
though he did also
you will get those every ten we don't
care about those because we got a
service that you can play it and reoccur
it and play it but these multiplayer
games and y'all
y'all y'all got to stop saying to
yourself and hoping for rainbows when
you see it snowing and raining outside
it's exactly what you see
he said he's going in this direction he
hasn't lied at all really
generation
generation
he believed in the playstation 4
generation and people didn't understand
what he was talking about
from this standpoint they've tried to do
this already before but they lost a
bidding war they try to buy the company
that makes warframe
like they tried that at like a year and
a half two years ago so
you know that that might have been their
initial kick the door down get that
company and do this with because
warframe's the only other game i could
think of that's on this success rate
unless they're gonna go out and buy like
buy like epic for fortnight or something
they couldn't
they they they've been trying they've
been sliding epic a little money here
and there it's like it's like how do you
feel about this
how do you feel about that it's
interesting yeah good
no it's just the fact that i'm just
listening and it's it's y'all like is
y'all in denial
[Music]
you are an endangered species and and
you think it's it's gonna stay that way
no it's not all right you are a truly
endangered species because there is no
revenue in you
right so you have to understand that
they put so much money in making you
happy and you not giving it back yes the
10 million strong that's your core
that's your base those are dues that you
can count on to come to the club night
in and night out what they do want is
those out-of-town dudes
and the out-of-town dudes just don't
like your club like that
like that right you ain't got that
louisiana baton rouge bump down there
your club is exclusive is the triple
like buying us bro so what you really
need to do you need to mix that gumbo up
and get it nice and good and frothy
everybody can partake in this right here
so that's what jim saw jim saw he came
down he had some crawfish in his teeth
and he said
i'm gonna tell you right now i can make
something very good like that live
service crawfish right okay hey remember
what was that shebang shrimp and forrest
gump he said aye man we could take this
worldwide we can franchise this why are
you selling it in this one little spot
they say you know what
how about if we sprinkle some french
fries in it that's the multiplayer
uh-oh and how about we put it all over
the place hey
i know what about we do crab cakes so
dudes ain't just coming over to looking
for your one single player banging
shrimp game they're not looking for that
they want crab cakes
lemon pepper wigs
right they're coming for the whole gumbo
mix the whole thing so jim knows that
and he knows y'all wasn't enough he told
you to your face and he went out and got
a trophy chick and the trophy chick said
i'm down with you if i'm for the street
and jim said whatever it takes to get
this deal done i don't care what you do
as long as you present a united front
and help us get to the space we want to
get because we want to sell gumbo to the
world you're tired of selling shrimp to
the same dude that coming down the block
we want gumbo to the world so shout out
to jim to get that gumbo out to
everybody
listen man oh let me get mine this is
funny it's it's interesting i i will
admit i've i've never seen a deal like
this i i was
even with the activision blizzard when a
lot of people were upset
you know at microsoft like damn like you
know you want call of duty so to speak
to be exclusive on xbox platforms and
microsoft had to acquiesce obviously you
know in lieu of the you know ftc and all
this other stuff and that makes sense
but the expectation
is for most of the games to you know
still be exclusive to xbox outside of
those let's say outside of maybe the
three let's say the three core
cod overwatch diablo let's just say
those three they decide you know what
we'll keep that everywhere and the live
service games like elder scrolls online
i mean i'll go excuse me but any um
um warzone or whatever but we'll see the
thing that's interesting like i said and
shout out to paul tassie he was like 3.6
billion and you get to keep all your
games and ip's multi-platform remains
one of the best deals i've seen for the
acquired party in this whole wide world
west wide west of acquisition and he's
right i've never seen anything like this
and to me to king's plate with the
trophy chick reference
she knows her worth yup she she's been
through enough bad relationships before
to understand that i'm not having it no
more and if you want me
these are the terms
and the crazy thing is sony say yo let's
do it because it aligns
what sony wants
sony wants to feel that deficiency
jim king is right jim ryan has made it
clear
this is a small box they consider their
games blockbusters they are not happy
with just being in that 10 million or
whatever it is that the bangers
currently do and that to me is live
service and you've got listen i see
people in the chat slam they're in
destiny all that's cute go to xbox most
played right now
and for the last five to six years that
game is not moved out of the top ten in
seasons where we think it's dead
hardcore destiny guys but i always dead
this season i play another game i'm
playing the rocket blade point uh bro
joy's still in top ten so that goes to
show you not only have they mastered the
live service formula they have mastered
the fps gun play no one shoot that gun
better no one has a better art team
design marketing team to get you excited
for the next season when people like oh
the game is dead yeah check the
engagement numbers so that's one thing
nobody could say to me about destiny you
may not like it for your reason that's
cool
but no one can say they have not
mastered the live service model and sony
sees that sony already had the
relationship to a third party through
activision
attic me and you saw they saw the one
thing you could say about sony they put
their p their finger on the pulse of
what's popping when a king will the king
remember this
let's be honest at the start of the ps4
generation out they were very indie
heavy they didn't have a lot of the
bangers weren't ready yet right so you
had the rezo guns right you had whatever
it was like the early everyday reliance
was on multi-platz and multi-patch
exclusives as far as like marketing
rights
destiny if you remember had a console
for playstation yep in the beginning
attic remembers very well exclusive maps
exclusive all this stuff that's them
showing yo this ip we don't have our
bangers yet let's associate ourselves
with this so that the base thinks that
this is
you can only get this here and a lot of
people let's be honest at the start of
destiny 1 2014 they gravitated towards
playstation to play it initially right
so they had the good relationship they
flirt and activision was kind of you
know proxy or whatever it was so now it
goes on to where it's at and i have to
admit i do think it's beneficial for
both sides now the truth remains to be
seen how long is going to last based on
bungie's history right but the way
she has this thing lined up
she's going to get what she wants
and remain her give her give or get keep
our autonomy the thing is going to be
interesting is how they help all the
live service model for these 10 live
service games that jim ryan and the team
wants right and it's going to be
interesting i want to see how their
influence goes there also bungie has a
lot of projects going on they have
matter and we got our news now it's
going to be in the destiny universe it's
going to be a competitive game you know
shooter maybe like a hero shooter in the
vein of uh overwatch you know what i'm
saying or something like that i would
actually play that if it was done right
yeah like imagine like you got a
team-based thing and you got zavala you
know what i'm saying osiris krogs
imagine just walking up oh sorry you're
so science to the left you know what i'm
saying that they got their own team like
because they they're looking at their
overwatch bag they're looking at that
you got that then you got to remember
bungie took the net ease back they got
the the um what you call it the um the
mobile model right maybe some type of
joint there that they get popping that
also bungee once they got aspirations
they see in these movies they want that
anime we're going to talk about netflix
at the moment they want things you know
what i'm saying so they they want
basically when the heads of this studio
what is it luke smith people oh they're
not p party he's the ceo but luke smith
the mark noseworthy i believe
get moved into a position of creator of
the destiny universe like controllers of
the almost the kevin feige of the lore
when you designate that that means you
want this thing to be bigger than video
games so that's where sony helps them
because we can say what they wanted so
they what do we got the uncharted movie
right they got things they doing up
they're doing the gran turismo move
they're doing movies like
listen this this works you know what i'm
saying for both parties and their
aspirations and it it's i think actually
as a person who initially wanted
microsoft to get them bungie i have to
admit i think the playstation situation
is better for them i think it does
because i don't know if microsoft's
allowing all of this
i'm gonna be honest i don't know of
microsoft allowing all and the money
they got they got a 3.7 so we'll see
we'll see it's very microsoft denied
them so they clearly didn't want to
invest that much into them maybe maybe
microsoft sting was like because we know
phil loves bungie phil was the first on
the front lines to retweet and celebrate
the acquisition the only concern i have
solve
is long term
obviously you know with the relationship
but one thing about bungie
love them i hate them they are very
outspoken on social issues
they are very outspoken in the political
climate and what's going on in the
awareness and
playstation and the brain trust for what
i see
tends to be like yo
we don't talk about those issues
that like we give you a frontline order
keep quiet
bless you quick keep quiet kind of chick
like like they go she going to talk and
they've already stated you know numerous
things outside about you know things
that's going on and someone says yo now
that you were playing do you think it's
going to stop that pre-pause is like
nope
so again i don't know if that's in the
contract or not but it has to be right
because they're they're in they're
they're purchased but they're an
independent subsidiary still
so
that that has to come along with clauses
right and i think that that that that's
definitely something they sat down and
talked about because
when we've talked about this in the past
it's like
you can have if you want to run your
company that way and you want to be up
front and talk about social issues
political things and and be able to talk
about that stuff you have to understand
that if you're part of a bigger entity
right you cannot you cannot project
those things onto the bigger entity you
can't so uh especially if they don't
want to take part in it so
this is something that they i'm sure
they work this into the contract so
they're going to talk what they're going
to talk i am curious on right now for
the most part bungie colliding with like
what what the masses want i'm curious on
when bungie aligns with something sony
don't want right that's going to get
tested was that going to change the
concept well i mean it already happened
because jim ryan was the one that came
up with it he didn't want people talking
about it he didn't like it's difference
between they don't want to talk about it
because they don't want to start any
kind of issue no but he didn't just say
i don't want y'all to talk about it he
said
everybody has the right to their opinion
and and the moment he said that he had
an opinion but that that's him trying to
be in the middle ground i'm curious on
what's going to happen
sony as a company not as jim ryan but
sony as a company don't believe in
something and bungie on simply said do
it do it punchy
you may be right so but i agree with
addict on this but like
bungie gonna be outside on social issues
they are never they said they will never
shut up no one can ever enter king's
point if you got a chicken i'm using
this before
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
what
breaks down before this happened they
said you will not silence anything i
said man
she's a head case
he's a head piece
listen he they them they are a head case
if they're telling you ahead of time the
definite don'ts don't mess with me um
for the streets don't mess with me i'm
going to have the mouth that i want to
have don't mess with me i'm doing
whatever i want to do and you look over
knowing that this is catastrophic stuff
in any relationship because we all know
in every relationship you got to be
almond armed with a single focus goal
yeah this is what i'm trying to tell you
guys
they do have a single focus goal
both of them want to be for the streets
and everybody keep trying to say not my
sony my sony don't ever want to do that
he's allowing a new acquisition you
don't think that mentality is not going
to corrupt all the other developers that
are there you don't think that mentality
you don't think naughty dog looks over
and sucker punch don't look over and say
what the hell why do you know what's the
chance to do this and they just got here
you know it's a good example of king
what king's talking about the game games
going to pc kojima put his game to pc
and before you know it everything go on
a pc so i do think it might have like
struck some internal discussions and
then that's what inevitably led to sony
going more towards everything but do
y'all think those things you're
mentioning weren't on paper already
like it happened fluidly that it
happened fluidly i'm gonna tell you
right now this breakup is not gonna come
from
bungee having a big mouth about things
it's gonna come from
and was gonna come from
when they asked them to do too much
on the development side of other games
yep when when it comes down to hey we
need what you were talking about cog
when it comes down to hey we need you to
work on the multiplayer aspect of this
game well wait wait
that's where the beef is going to come
from not this other stuff because this
stuff i'm telling you right now this is
stamped out in paper in writing that
that's already set so that argument
ain't going to happen
to your point
to what you're saying you know who
agrees with you shout out to thai guy
travis we had this conversation on the
last word
and ty guy's frustration is like look he
feels bungee with the chosen one they
were the last kind of like triple a but
by themselves not acquired by anyone so
he didn't like for whatever reason the
acquisition because he's thinking he's
he's
he says somebody's going to drain them
for their brain trust and their
knowledge and work them to the core that
he thoroughly believes this he for like
like that sweatshop level king but like
he he he is convinced and i got to give
my boy craig i mean this is just his
thought i don't agree with him but he is
convinced that they may have bitten off
more than they can chew because jim is
putting them to work on these live
service games and he's worried about
like destiny truly getting supported and
that the movie aspirations like he
worried about the content my only
counter to it is that
if you go in there right
that's with the assumption that you
gonna have the resources that's only
bungie's been problem to me if you look
at them historically through the destiny
franchise the issue has never been the
quality of the game it's just been the
sustaining the content right you know
yeah but those resources
most of the time they don't come free no
no that's true and it's going to be
interesting to see how that works out if
sony provides them the support they need
for the for and again they got multiple
projects destiny two maybe three if you
know um matter walk in they've
yeah hero shooter you know um 10 live
service games you know it kind of feels
like this relationship
is
it on the bungee side yeah obviously
they're going to help them but on the
bungee side it's like okay this
this partnership will allow us to grow
exponentially to where we get to the
point where we can just be
self-sufficient once again with all of
the new things that we've introduced to
the bungee burst
you you think that they that they
look like like they play in sony and the
moment they like okay
we've stacked up money we got money in
the
bank account that came is they
the moment we can sustain ourselves on
the movie front the tv show front on all
the cross media stuff and obviously the
game stuff is down packed once they're
there again
all of a sudden it's gonna be a
trying to say problem is like a certain
uh kardashian oh
oh my god
[Music]
man you think they're going kanye west
soda
let's see
i picked the initial foundation of this
relationship
listen i mean as long as
as long as everything is mutually
beneficial hey it doesn't matter who's
it doesn't matter if one is a parasite
or
they're both not together right so he's
going to get her to exposure and all
that stuff and the ability to make the
clothing lives and do all that stuff and
she's going to give a couple of kids but
speaking of clothing child support he
always
[Laughter]
[Music]
outside oh
oh
no
camouflage get back salute to y'all for
supporting your fashion chances but
y'all need a bag that's what
crocs let's get a bag for this bad
fashion
does continue spring sell crocs
[Laughter]
now we don't want teespring croc bro you
know what the teeth
as soon as you get a ray of sunlight on
them they burn up
your whole
one time you guys made me wear overalls
oh that would yeah
that was crazy we are
thank you
we're going to be forced into this and
they're going to be so comfortable
we do a crocodile we're going to do a
tcl tier 2. yeah all right but hey i
ain't worried about that we're going to
get those questions
playstation 5 for six months too yeah
yeah
let's get crazy let's get generation the
rest of the generation
what type of crap is that yeah you want
me to listen you gonna do what you don't
like to do check it out check it out and
we're gonna have a tear that you can
only play turbo graphics oh i'm down for
that
put me on there
talk about you don't get it
i'm talking about h yeah yeah you gotta
put it up
he would go crazy
what type
can only play the ps5 for six months and
i only could play the turbo graphic
[ __ ]
yo i'm gonna tell you right now and i'm
gonna keep it turn your bike up a little
bit it's gotta be a bike level it's
still low
if they left me on the desert island for
five months and they said you could take
your playstation or windows volume turbo
graphics i will kick that playstation so
far down the block
your bestie anyway so look that's what i
gotta stop it guys there we go there we
go all right so yeah like i said shout
out to paris because chaos already um
yeah we see how these things go but the
deal is done time to watch and check it
out shout out to fastline he said make
sure to like yeah hit this like and
subscribe y'all we give y'all
entertainment we having fun we doing
what we're doing let's get this super
chat song when we move on back we got uh
dirk it puts the crest in the chat for
dirt griggity remember lord bronze
that's our dude thank you brother
then we got donald otaku 2 super chat
not being ps exclusive could mean ps and
pc only i think that is a lot of that
the terminology for some of their games
definitely would be that but we'll see
if bungie's influences uh pushes them to
put it on other platforms
lord metroid five dollars for chat
and i quote bungie we're married my love
sony yes honey till death do us part
bungee takes off the ring sony what the
hell bunzie i'm out slay queen
ps made its bed in single player they've
tried multiplayer and failed ps player
base doesn't care about multiplayer xbox
has cod halo gears eso warcraft along
with en2k sports and game pass
playstation needs pc xbox for
multiplayer
we'll see we'll see maybe i don't know
that they see it that way at pc
definitely i don't know about xbox we'll
see
there we go hard to find two live super
chat a 3.7 billion dollar open
relationship is absolutely insane man
right now that seems like it's happening
with activision that's even more insane
then
bill yeah you you're sitting there with
the whole cap
the games of the service games is gonna
be that way and dudes is going to look
at there's no way in hell and i'm being
like real games though
there's a lot of their games yeah yeah
yeah that's
the games that i'm i don't really care
about whatever games you make new that's
going to be exclusive to that that
platform it's cool it's gonna happen
that way but we talking about this one
thing if activision signs and be like yo
and by the way
we still for the streets and and run off
the stage this dude literally gets up
there and say yo you know what for a
fact though what we said before what we
said after as soon as the deal is done
the deal don't even get a chance that
nobody's sipping champagne yet they
still pop in the bottle like yeah we
just and don't forget before you take a
sip
um
and for the record i'm on the
king's point i'm on the right on the
record on the bungee net next site the
all the acquisition it says still to
this day question bungie has future
games in development will they now
become playstation exclusives bungie's
dancer no
we want the worlds we are creating to
extend to anywhere people play games we
will continue to be self-published
creatively independent and we will
continue to drive one unified bungee
community that's that's really what's
happening and i think i think for
playstation when you think about the
fact 3.7 billion in operation is
absolutely insane
i think the open relationship is the
only way that 3.7 billion works because
when you think about you talked about
nettie's before
if that mobile money starts popping the
3.7 billion is a steal my friend a live
stream yeah a live service shoot like
kickstarter
i wasn't saying nothing about the 3.7 i
was saying activision something similar
too like because a lot of their game is
going to be multiplied yeah that
diamonds
new games is going to be in development
it's going to be on that platform only
those existing games the game of service
that the the philosophy is different but
if you look at different spaces though
it's just that the game pass philosophy
is different
i feel you but you look at the
activision of blizzard the majority of
blizzard their games are only on pc
right uh then you look at activision all
of their studios are making call of duty
and those are going to be
right all over the place right and and i
totally agree with you but we all right
see there's no fear with microsoft
as far as that goes like you know hey
putting my game's head they when once
you make halo free to play
fair was out the window a long time ago
dudes don't there's no fear there
we're talking about the depth of a whole
brand structure right if the brand
philosophy switches
on the core fan base
how do they react
how do how how do
these single-player story-driven closet
dude
and females and gamers how do they react
to this narrative being broken in front
of them i see where you're going but the
reality is we know twitter is an echo
chamber bro that does not
and the board don't care boy don't care
about
the 10 and the boy don't care about 20
people on twitter being mad the boys
care about what you call them the the
out of town dude
they want out-of-town money-less that's
what it is
that's what makes money making it all
like crying on twitter you don't
represent the whole of the thing right
let me explain why i knew sony was
always inching towards what microsoft
was doing microsoft always wanted to be
everywhere
always
they always wanted inclusion
they were the first to give a modem
ethernet they was the first team
hard drive they was the first to give a
mic in the box actually right the user
interfaces is always geared to
uh expansion literally created the xbox
live that everybody is getting to that
space as well
like if
from the platinums to the microphones to
all that stuff to the to to the the uh
the group chats and in the room partner
with microsoft azure
this stuff is geared towards what
microsoft is going to and that's the
fear
that's the terrible realization
of the base
and i don't care but i'm just telling
dudes that's where it's going
we've been saying it we remember we got
killed people coming here that's what
they're doing
i'm like all right
your leaders are saying otherwise the
dudes that you pledging you're a dying
field team to are telling you different
so get ready and now that has happened
and it's not to talk it's just how the
industry is going and we got to be a
realist about it the conversation as
soon as you're making a deal first of
all you don't need to say that could you
please shut up police for one day i mean
just just for one day just let let
twitter say let the world say let the
paper say
the deal went through shut up
just let let let them say the deal went
through
it's just they can't get out of their
way with trying to tell you i'm still
gonna be the biggest loud mouth
[Laughter]
i'm like like oh okay i understand you
from the hood i don't care you're not
gonna control me like you like all right
calm down yeah like you're restating the
obvious always yeah like we already we
talked about that i just want the world
to know
you know because yo don't do this you're
david
[Music]
i see the problems already
ahead of time and you know how y'all
don't front you have always went to
somebody's wedding you sat and was like
this ain't gonna work that's what you
say come on
they saying all the great things up
there and you just like whoa i'ma tell
you right now they got a good spread of
food out here
but these dudes i get these dudes
you already have to wear you in the back
tea like hot already you already pick
your sides like should we give them a
gift for the wedding because i don't
think they're gonna
give you some instant rice because this
is good
you ain't giving that long-term buddy
give them how did that do it you
that's my man i'm giving him a band
and then the other dude that you know
the relationship ain't gonna work you
give him a bus pass
oh my god gift certificate like yeah
that's my joint 50 cent
like that gift card it's that gift card
energy yeah this is exactly what it
feels like it feels like it's an
imminent breakup dudes is in there
talking everybody whispering i don't
think they're gonna
he drive her to the house and all of
that
you know
you just seen this and why is gossip at
your wedding
you know it's supposed to be a joyous
occasion and dude is like oh she's still
outside
you know you know the messed up thing is
everybody know i'm right
listen one thing about you with your
percentages as much as your cloud a lot
of times you'll be on it i i got it
better needed you on that a lot of times
i give you a lot of crap but sometimes
like there you have seen some stuff that
would happen i saw it when she said it
oh good god
we gotta read the next one
scrub those remember for 26 months
so king you're saying that sony is
holding the webcam for bungie's internet
endeavor
[Music]
the crest in the chat yeah put the
crescent attack
we got suicide kings remember for 21
months imagine what happens on this
podcast if god of war would have missed
its release date by even one day
slashing
over yet bro
it's gotta get delayed two months before
i don't know oh
here we go
i told you
this
this is how it happens
this is how it is this is how it happens
one series this year
fish bruh
it is july and they announced the
release date now if you move that you
know i'm sorry i would have to defer the
gig of a deal
listen there's no deferring it we do we
agree on it coming out this year you
need to bring those receipts you got to
bring the receipts bring the receipts
i'm not saying that you guys
if it's not that i agree with king that
if it misses its date even if it comes
out december or whatever now you know
you know either way you're going to get
to spoke though you know
go to the video to add it go to the
videotape
just go to the video if you write and
you say yeah then uh or whatever but
let's be honest though even if this year
november like there's only one more
month like there's a strong chance if we
get the put it the kid you're good
at going
it's not gonna come out most likely most
likely
[Laughter]
this is the case to know that no matter
what you know king is not going to stay
quiet oh this is that guy not at all
we go to the videotape
there we have donald trump
notice every sony single-player game
this gen has been shorter with less
content and or less polished than before
they're moving that budget elsewhere
it happened already uh-huh i mean i
can't i can't say that because
i mean i don't know what people's
thinking on on uh forbidden west was but
polish was there for well first week i
heard there was some stuff
but i mean the budget's there it's just
i don't know i don't know
i get it how some people can see that
but i don't know i think their content
is still strong
then we have black addict
black addiction are you serious
black addict
super chat he's saying i'm the real
addict are you serious
that is ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
on racial
changes
my co-host
let's go then we got hollywood rules 5
good afternoon lords thank you for
another great iop sunday activision
netflix we renaming game pass but borg
will you
you will be you will be assimilated phil
spencer yeah
uh yes this is the expanding the reach
that's for sure okay
then we got the man who got them horns
much love to everyone hashtag for the
streets hashtag crocs hashtag
sweatshirts oh he down with kick in the
crocs ah cracks team stand up
then we got necromancer zale member for
nine months
when iop gets that croc money i want cog
doing the infomercial like the advanced
gg employees
with alligators and crocodiles let's get
him let's let's get him some
queensbridge finest
listen shout out the kick make sure
y'all get him that croc back we want to
see him in the finest of crocs but that
is the barbecue crocs
that's all you brother i'm supporting
your movement
then we have pragmatic eagle member for
33 months thank you sir thank you
brother hit that like button you aren't
finding this kind of entertainment
anywhere
facts hit the subscribe too
don't want the console 15k i get a
console let's go get the console get
more giveaways get let's get the
subscribers up tell a friend tell them
[Music]
we're giving you all free powder he
gives me some cracks you look over at me
and we get stuck into the
situation once they get the iop croc
when we go to these gaming events guess
who got to be crying
i will not sign that deal in sports move
is going to be in sports he's going to
flip him back and go hold on what do you
bicep curls in on this one right here
yeah
we gonna get it on advanced gg and the
products
that will be your bag
eventually gonna send you an email
tomorrow
if that bag is right i'll start doing it
like i started
nick listen even even your camera trying
to save you this is true cut it out
so baby is what it is is that the state
of the world god of war comes out this
year next year
oh he got it got it
keep
this is the easiest been the knees i've
ever had
and i bring up sharing my screen
you know what's crazy about my joint i
don't even got to bring up a screen i
got enough dudes that got good memory
and they can make their own memes
i got we got a betty b the attic attic
had the receipt he was on deck he's
trying he's trying he's trying to stay
relevant
in november and it's going to slip
but
it's gonna slip
just like you you're gonna slip i'm
gonna send you some slip proof crocs
[Laughter]
i'm just
hold on a second let me go back for a
moment we got
[Music]
oh then we got pragmatic eagle no no
that's it we're caught up no we got new
ones yeah we got we got it we got okay
give me one you gotta practice that was
the last oh we got yes smelly wrestling
geek ah ten dollar super chat how do you
guys feel about digital content that was
purchased being removed from the
purchaser's library do you think this
could drive consumers back to physical
media
um we talked a little bit about this
last week with the
the stuff leaving the uh i forgot what
the heck the name of the store was oh
the uh ps supplies yeah that was in
australia yeah yeah
thing about physical media is that the
switch has already happened the problem
with physical media is nine times out of
ten the game that you get on a disc
isn't playable without anything without
it
content so and [ __ ] and shout out to kai
for helping me find that wait i helped
you out with the background just now no
no no this time stamp so
straight to the box you always get this
listen listen
you're sitting in there and you're
busting too early bro like i'm trying to
save you from yourself because this is a
bad fall all you got to do is say
see you when it come out bro you already
got to bend the knee and walk away and
you good right so so you're not putting
no extra sauce right now you putting
extra cheese on your burger and you're
gonna walk away from the table and
you're gonna trip and your burger gonna
be all over the floor and you're gonna
get it next year and the sad part about
it is you had your mouth salivating you
the dude on the line like yo this is
going to be the best whopper that i've
ever had and they got bacon and they got
the yottenham edition and you're going
to turn the corner and it's going to
spill and then say sir you have to wait
to the end of the line and that's next
year and that's going to be you and i'm
going to be in the back saying i told
you
that burger pointing about what's that
are you done
with it
anyway we're going to see what happens
move it let's get some chicken
okay cool we got gamerbot choice five
dollars which i iop needs that bend the
knee instant replay and review yeah we
got today
like like an nfl nfl yeah
we had to go to the video tape make sure
he was in bounds
no doubt
that we got uh the skills the skills
town remember for nine months thank you
sir seven months of the crocs movement
the lord of crocs in this salute to you
and your bad father choice salute to you
that's right shout out to you your
beautiful feet
that's that croc energy
right now i know his feet is in heaven
i'm gonna tell you right now if the bag
is right i will do feet asmrs
oh
this is where i lead
they loose
there we go all i know is this is going
so serious i can't have my face being on
this side i can't be associated with
this i'm not associated with this
there's aj you next
there we go
forget netflix i want electronic arts
okay white gig absolutely black addict
in the house let's do it
no they still with this white yo they
why later
i told you it's dope
continue
then we got necromancer's sail five
dollar super chat [ __ ] how big does that
croc bag gotta be for the cog crackers
they gotta hit the stipulations they
gotta get my man he's on the front line
my man king's on the front line for
these crocs he got to get a bag he got
to do and he got to be a secure bag for
the team once they do that because he
putting a brand and they metric to the
universe because of my man i'll give him
that my man is putting them on the map
so crocs holler at him if you want cop
first of all cock's not wearing crocs
but if you want to
do a commercial you know what i'm saying
and if it's a joint that you know for
the team yeah i'll do that
and then i'll hold a picture on king's
feet and this is how i look
at something on king's
i don't take nothing for the team
but i respect the team and i want the
team to get the bag my man is out so he
got the numbers up we're going to get
this patreon tear together we're going
to get a pair of wu-tang crocs
and yo
me me and kyle gonna dress up no you
know what you know what addict said it
right
addict said it right
we gonna get the my adidas crocs
gonna be dmc and attic gonna be bimmy
we gonna be outside we go my uh
fam and i'm gonna support y'all from a
distance and i'm like look at my bros
doing that look at my bros it's gonna be
dope what's it no no no let's uh on a
real man we should have some kind of
special part i'll put the overalls back
on enough
yo listen i want y'all to write knives
right now right to have nas put out
a prepare and he gonna sign him and say
queen's bridge fighting
that was with him
have happened yo
listen man let me tell you something cog
you owe me this one man
you owe me some rocks on your feet
never blessing my
i know he's such a fan of mob deep oh
yeah shout out to the player i know he's
a fan of mobbed
face prodigy
your boy havoc want one one half of mob
deal down so he's in
this is how you press to do new york
city press
over you know you using the area because
i got i got energy i got good energy at
the urinal i got good energy so i get up
i don't wash my hands from the good
energy
and you know and i'm saying i'm gonna
let the man finish his situation
then i run down on him like yo
my cousin is a fan of you
you don't know if this is your last
moments
and he says hello yeah he put havoc on
the phone
that's right you know yeah yeah that's
right
you gonna speak to my man so i just need
you to get on some cracks just love it
i'm gonna get you
and you will have all the love you want
and i will never grace those disgusting
footwear on my feet ever there's nothing
you could do i'm gonna tell you i'm
stopping i will fight y'all all the way
i will never win it it's all about
getting y'all a bag though
absolutely
let me put on some overalls but carl
can't wear chrome oh stop i noticed i
ain't doing that
on people in the urinals
you get me to introduce your commercial
yo listen listen listen some solve have
a urinal story too
whoa
moving on let's get on with the show
yeah there's another super chat that
came in oh
hold on a second let me just let me let
me let me just get through this
hold on it's like we got that then we
got white cards
that was
[Music]
you can go white or you can go
we got carlos alvarado two dollars of a
chat halo forge leaks and co-op is
looking fire so excited yeah it has
anybody
we got to try it this week we did it
yeah yeah
the only thing i'm doing today is
working on a review i can't do anything
today it's going to take my whole day i
don't i'm not in that beta program you
know nah you ain't breaking my xbox
then we got xboxes on paris lockhart ten
dollar super chat like and subscribe
cognito will wear special edition crocs
live on stream
15k
listen brother we will all be here
listen
i love you you know you're the homie
you're the own team but and i support
your your fashion choice whatever you
choose to do in your home
outside no no whatever you listen i
support that love everybody that that's
your personal decisions
i like my feet i like good fly stuff for
my feet that's not happening brother so
you can keep putting your little tweets
you can put cracks in xbox live messages
to send
microsoft
supports adidas as the official shoe
guess what i supported that so you need
to fall in line with the team
the team said they're not doing crocs
the team said adidas so salute the
adidas salute the greedy suit everybody
wear the official xbox merchandise
paris but paris is moving them in a
different direction
the brass is not listening
so salute to you for your movement more
power to you there will be no crocs or
cars
[Laughter]
brother let me play with your joystick
five dollar super chat
how big does the bag gotta be for saab
to take one for the team
wow
that's the croc energy stuff i'll be
talking about this is the stuff
totally different
from the feats to the streets
to the sheets that man love himself
nothing to do with it
does not endorse that nor do we uh
support this so uh yeah that's that's
that's that's straight i mean
endorsements
who did that
i don't know that's that sounds like
you're no energy to me
this is
please
get through the show
we got hard to find two dollars
duplicate i'm with cog hashtag say no to
lord cry crack exactly yo and this one
this is the movement you know because
y'all go y'all keep acting up i'll tell
you i don't bet that don't break yeah
keep acting i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna do a gu knock campaign on
y'all i'm gonna put i'm gonna put the
symbol and no alligators already started
leave me alone i will stop the movie
before you want to gilly to get it
y'all don't want to play with me i've
been nice i've been letting y'all live
your life y'all keep coming at me with
this crap
y'all
stop it i want my man to get a bag so
leave me alone
overalls
he did that willingly
no i did not go back and watch that you
guys
he said i've been bullied
he's pulling this bully card yeah
we got necromancer sale five dollars of
attack we need to get kangas special
edition xbox crocs when iop gets that
croc back yes
i can't get the bag it's gonna be lit
it's gonna be the lord
i'm gonna be just
remember what we said in the beginning
remember i was not part of that contract
like everybody else i got to opt out i'm
not part of that
i got pre-dumps and all that
if oculus is like crocs are our new
brand partners for footwear
what you gonna do
they won't get no retweets from me
it ain't my contract to promote nothing
over there
i just work there
i'm not obligated to say nice things
they're on the business uh retreat to
for communications and they all walk in
and they got to put on the cracks
everybody's individual cracks
have some herbal tea have some herbal
tea everybody sit down relax we're going
to do yoga some hot yoga first
shout out to shout out to texas lean in
the in the chat put in a game pass
ultimate code for the family out there
so whoever got it congrats shout out to
you sir appreciate that no doubt no
doubt all right we are caught up finally
yes sir finally all right topic number
two jesus oh my god jesus it's gonna be
a fast one it is it's our own fault it's
our own fault solve what's going on with
uh microsoft focus cracks ah well
it appears that microsoft has won the
war the bidding war with uh comcast uh
nbc universal and probably google as
well to serve as the adversa advertising
technology uh
partners for um
streaming services well specifically for
netflix
um
and this is a big deal
so basically netflix is going to
implement a an ad-supported tier which
say i don't believe they've done before
um so they obviously needed a partner to
go in on them with them with uh for
advertising
and there were a few sort of big
companies and the running of microsoft
managed to sort of edge out these other
two big companies
to become their advertising partner this
is huge because microsoft has really
only
advertised with bing in the past right
their own platform
um
so now
they're out there they're out there and
this is this is big i know
this caused speculation about people per
of them purchasing netflix and all this
other stuff
maybe something like that happens down
the line but
as of right now this is just
a way of netflix is still popular right
but it has lost a lot of subscribers
recently because the fact of the matter
is that as soon as the prices start
going up
people start canceling and you know
netflix now regular prize racing like
they raise those prices like two or
three times a year sometimes
yeah it's been it's been the cadence has
been a lot quicker as of late and you
know i'm again i'm at the top tier and
it's 20 bucks a month
when at one point it was like 10 maybe
less than that you know and they charge
different uh prices for for different
sort of bandwidth like if you have the
4k hdr all that niceness that's the 20
tier so now they're trying to get in
with an ad supported tier where somebody
can you know it's going to be a
considerably lower for bar for entry
and
probably 10 bucks the way you do it well
what is their lowest here now it is 10
bucks so it would have to be lower than
that so they might go back to the seven
raise everything again and put that at
the top right if they move the needle
again right then then we're gonna see
different tiers um so this this is very
interesting because again mike it's not
like microsoft doesn't make money hand
over fists in other ways this is just
another thing that's going to generate
money and enhance the the scope of their
reach
so what do you guys think about this
specifically and how it affects micros
uh xbox and and its reach and microsoft
and it's reached um and then what do you
think about the speculation about what
can come
from this on the gaming side because
there's been a lot of speculation about
oh you know you know netflix is getting
into gaming they bought uh night school
studios and stuff like that
how can this affect you know xbox and
gaming so first off like overall what
does this mean for microsoft what you
feeling about netflix me microsoft
partnership
i think it's just business it's just
like when
you know
we're from we cover a different industry
so
obviously there will be some of us that
see
the company that you cover make a move
and you automatically assume it's for
your interesting no it's just like the
sony thing with buying uh crunchyroll
and funimation like these people do more
than just one thing
like just because they're partnering
with netflix to do a
some form of ad advertisements to people
like oh they're buying they're buying
netflix
who who makes pop tarts
nothing on them did we say they're gonna
buy pop tarts like
it's just like come on man let's let's
let's let's tune it back
just because a company's working company
microsoft was working with the nfl
before we gonna say they're buying the
nfl next but it's just like relax
relax man this is strictly for financial
reasons because netflix needs some form
of competition because they can't they
keep overspending on the
the service they have and now they need
something of that bare minimum
subscription rate to have advertising
sent so they're able to keep up with
competition that's all this is there's
nothing deep rooted oh that matters
it sounds like you're a bit angry at the
masses on twitter
[Laughter]
it's more of a
why can't i feel like a lot of these
state like a lot of the disappointment
that comes in communities is
self-inflicted
like now backwards doesn't get bothered
no that's a good point that's a good
point now that people have these like
kids move having these crazy
expectations for the event last time now
everyone's disappointed that listening
to kids smooth like i feel like a lot of
the times it's it's it's definitely
self-inflicted like like we got to be in
the realms of reality something makes
sense something makes sense let's talk
about it but this in no way shape or
form makes sense so that microsoft is
buying netflix never no chance okay zero
percent whoa
maybe ten i'll give
microsoft should buy all w all of wwe
slash discovery see that so that's it
because that is a gaming company
so again man what's your thoughts on
this
um microsoft that's bigger than what
you know um
attic try to simplify this
it's just the course of business and
i literally said that that was you know
i said it came out of my way and i said
you are simplifying it it's more than
that that's
what right
um
microsoft was trying to buy discord
they're looking at bases that are
uh
funding they need funding in certain
aspects and how they can work with them
and how they can use their fan base
their base they subs
to
enhance their subs remember they wanted
3
billion user base this is this is the
thought process right and how you
achieve that goal
is all incumbent on how you attack the
puzzle
so for years companies have well gaming
companies have been attacking the puzzle
in the same manner and it hasn't
yielded that large
return as they hoped it's been the same
numbers basically over and over again
you pretty much know that your title is
going to do this
and what you want is a breakout
situation right and how do you do that
you first got to have a subscriber base
that is equal to the base that you're
looking to attack right
netflix has a huge subscriber base
now
everywhere game pass is
or can be
phil wants his stuff there
yeah you do a partnership where you have
a low tear that you subsidize
uh some of them of netflix add tear and
you roll that inside to your game pass
or your tears on your stuff like that is
a win-win situation
you get the exposure to their subs
and they get the subsidies and another
tear and they get exposure to your subs
so one hand washes the other but in this
business it's not as cold and cut as
this is what's happening on the surface
it's also how can i get a future bag
with you how can we create money
not just
all right we're just sharing fan bases
and and cross-pollinating no when you go
into one of these big deals how can we
expand and grow
and make money
if microsoft
and
netflix does a partnership a hundred
billion dollar partnership which is like
easy for them to do they already have a
small structure inside netflix that is a
gaming structure microsoft has a huge
structure that is a gaming structure
right so how do you get access to
something that you want really badly
microsoft wants access to their
worldwide global reach
with netflix you know i told people
before
there's so many people that have a
netflix account
and
it's it's like breathing it's like if
you tell somebody that you don't have
netflix it's already assumed that you
got it when you talk to somebody right
that's a huge assumption microsoft wants
to be in that category and wants to be
in that so
if they can
buy them
and they keep the uh autonomy in the
sense that they still able to use their
reach in the same form as bungie
it's still for the streets they're still
able to get their reach
and microsoft gets to use them i can see
a deal like this being done where
microsoft is saying oh it's not going to
be exclusive to us it's all over we're
just using their global reach in a
manner that is conducive for us and a
real branding will take place over a
period of years but can i ask a question
real quick so are you saying that if
they were to buy them it wouldn't be
for any type of yeah it's kind of like
the the sony and bungie thing it's
mainly for what they can provide
they're trying to buy networks for the
analytics to see what does their what
that's like
how to push this stuff yeah and to be
honest with you king like if you look at
it from perspective you know that's why
i want to give it to 10 percent because
microsoft is sitting on a on on bank
accounts that are losing that monetary
value because of inflation and stuff so
i could see them using that money it's
just i don't know
because
i just don't know if netflix would be
willing to sell that company because
like sure they they have a little bit of
ups and downs but you know it's arguably
you can argue that netflix is still the
top dog in streaming service yeah but
okay and to your thing let me let's say
if you're netflix and i come to you and
i say listen
i want to purchase you
but i want you to still be for the
streets
you're not going to change who you are
right this is i mean this is really a
sweetheart deal this is the same
sweetheart deal that sony came to with
bungie
same sweetheart deal
right but this is certain things that i
want i want this stuff here and i'm not
going to end i'm not going to put
netflix and game pass ultimately
that's that's that's what i'm talking
about that's what i'm talking about i'm
talking about that level of global reach
and the thanos snap
so like okay i will raise mine to 25.
so so can you say like
potential
like maybe netflix
in the game pack like what was that line
you said you said i say it's it's like
you you get netflix you bundle netflix
inside sometimes like game password or
something like that and then have that
cross okay
okay and inside the highest tip because
you just said it yourself addict uh uh
netflix is going up at least two three
times a year man and they're not giving
you any more perceived value to your
thing other than the movies well what if
game pass in some form or fashion was
wrapped up into the ultimate tier hd
tier of netflix it was subsidized by the
lower tier that has the ads real quick
oh man they're buying a lot of they did
okay they buy a lot of merch i gotta
shout them out because if they did
eventually get them which i'm not saying
they would
microsoft has showed interest in wanting
to be in the tv and movie scene that
would be the perfect dumping site for
that content would be to give value to
another service you owned if they were
to ever remotely buy now because
remember they did have studios before
when don was in charge you know studios
cut down and closed up but they still
always uh envied and wanted to be in
that realm sony is already there that's
their pedigree that's why they were able
to deliver such cinematic and and
thoughtful stuff because they have these
individuals on site that can help you
direct this day in the third imagine
having access to that level of uh of
stuff that you won't have the halo
series look like the halo series how it
did it it kind of looked a little bit
better if you have a little bit more of
an insight on movie production i'll
figure let me jump in real quick before
i start oh shout out anonymous somebody
got the four horsemen t you know what
they just cop that you don't say it or
sweet spring anonymous and he also cop
that all
natty from king he got that in green
salute to you make sure when you're
doing the checkout so y'all get the
shout out make sure you leave a comment
so you can get your balls we can read
what you say at when you buy it so we
give you the proper shout out but up
yeah let me all get my balls this is
interesting um
i'm gonna it's funny i went when i first
write heard about it i kind of was kind
of addicted like all right
you know [ __ ] talk to me a little bit
more in the middle but not much more
okay
he talked me completely left of jumping
off the left
okay maybe i'm close to the middle field
my thing was at first okay what does
this mean they're partnering with them
you see uh satya put out the statement
we're thrilled netflix has selected
microsoft as its advertising technology
and sales partner we want publishers to
have more long-term viable ad
monetization platforms so more people
can access the content where they love
wherever they are so that was the
initial joint and then um
also on microsoft's blog today's
announcement endorses microsoft approach
to privacy which is built on protected
customers information um and then uh the
bunch called president of web
experiences macau pereiran i don't know
if i pronounce it he said um outside of
netflix you know microsoft also
reportedly looking into bringing ads to
free to play xbox games so i was like
okay
helping them out there and we got to be
real too like
netflix
they've been hurting recently right
they've been hurting and they've been
downsizing a bit right and their
subscription tears and we have to be
honest
you know when you see downsizing you see
people
stripping things
sometimes you may be either looking to
get out the game or
getting yourself more sexy for
acquisition
the other thing
is
we have to admit there is a strong
long-term relationship here and i got to
give something to credit so what i never
give credit to someone that i have
slandered a lot of iop i got to give a
shout out to the doll dawn matrix and
the reason why is one of the things
during the end of the xbox 360 era
was netflix was first
to work and have on beyond 360.
that was a big deal at the time if you
remember king and solve like and i
remember when i helped them remember
that ability to watch movies with your
avatars
netflix they took it away but it was
like a cool thing like you covered there
like obviously i'm with meta so we have
they have something similar which is um
you you have like your home and you
bring people into your home they can see
your house whatever and then there's an
app called big screen where you could do
kind of what that 360 version was doing
which is you have your friends we have
the avatars we watch the movie we throw
a party called we cheer it and we're
watching the movie together so i always
thought that was interesting that those
two had that relationship and they let
them on board you know initially
now again i was like all right maybe
this is just that don't get too crazy
maybe they may subsidize a netflix you
know subscription in the end or
something like how um these guys did
with um paramount plus you know game
pass you get a little paramount plus or
something a little deal here and there
but here's the thing where i i sent this
to kig and i got to say that to y'all
this the thing that really got my
attention let me send it to y'all first
through um what you call it chassis i
can see this but um the thing that got
me is yahoo finance had put something
out
and the thing here we go homelessness
you don't know what i'm talking about
yeah i could see it
all right
basically
he suspects that there's that one of
these financial analysts expecting could
be a hidden agenda here by microsoft and
he says ana slams netflix microsoft
concealer says deal conceals hidden
agenda he says that he thinks shout out
to laura martin the senior analyst he
said that um she said that it could be
that netflix is looking for an exit
and the analysts went on to explain that
no other company that netflix could have
partnered would have been able to make
the 100 billion purchase either due to
financial constraints or regulatory
issues they said netflix is trying to
get closer to microsoft in hopes that
after microsoft digest its activision
acquisition it turns and buys netflix
next and we are it is funny because i
wanted to see like
where would microsoft go because that's
the big hurdle right now all hands on
deck for activision blizzard
they're going to get a ton of content if
that finalizes right but then what's the
next big into king's point they saw them
trying to flirt with discord right they
didn't get that one but like
this is another area we got to keep our
eye on you know what i'm saying we have
to keep on to see what th that thing
what this relationship could potentially
bear fruit and i think it there's a part
of me that thinks that this could make
sense long term i just got to see the
structure of the deal how it would play
with gay basketball we do know netflix
was has gaming studios right they're
trying to get yeah in the gaming if
there was something i want to
bring up a part go for them shout out to
everborn um for texting me relentlessly
right now right
and and
i'm gonna flesh out your point uh with
my point because i don't like to
regurgitate somebody else's point sure
therefore it's not my point but you
brought up something that i've thought
about on the back end so everyone's
talking about the fact that uh netflix
pays aws you know a ton of money mm-hmm
uh getting that stuff out of it
file-based services
and
this would be a major blow because
remember microsoft doesn't look at sony
as a as a competitor they look at google
and they look at amazon right and
if microsoft can
disrupt or actively
uh remove a large
portion of revenue away from aws and
internally put netflix on um the azure
cloud uh system they become the number
one streaming in terms of uh streaming
content in a single stroke without
crippling
your
main competitor that's to the left of
you
and that will give google pause
in doing anything because we already
knew uh google removed basic funding
from uh stadia because of what happened
with game pass and phil's brilliant
moves there so this move right here
given you know this will probably be a
satya move to be honest with you
on that type of a level has absolutely
nothing to do with uh phil and the xbox
team
this is a cloud war type of a thing and
if you can [ __ ] one of the main
people in the cloud structure base by
removing their their one of the biggest
biggest streaming content
i think i think that's the incentive
here i think that's the underlining uh
dagger that's being hit shout out to one
mother he actually has some points too
he said co-founder of netflix reed
hastings was a nadella mentor before
nutella took top seed at microsoft he
understands their business and potential
synergies not sure if it's a bio but
it's more we just got i agree we got to
keep an eye out on this yeah
you know they've definitely got to keep
an eye on it and there's more to it than
even that because when you think when
you
like your mini conspiracy theory thing
oh is that where it's you know like you
said cog it's like it seems like they
were preparing themselves for purchase
when you think about microsoft in this
space
six or seven months ago
they wouldn't have been able to beat out
a comcast
they would not have been able to beat
out google because they didn't have the
advertise they didn't have the tools to
to compete against those
six or seven months ago this is you know
what they did
they purchased what is called xander
from att
zander
is basically the backbone of it was
basically the backbone of of online
advertising for for for programmatic
global online advertising that at t
utilized and they sold that to microsoft
probably the end of 2021 right
so when you think about the steps that
are being taken for something to happen
in the future
this
and this isn't specifically talking
about the gaming stuff that you were
talking about king in terms of like
like leveraging the xbox stuff yeah this
is on just the pure advertising side of
it and the money that it's going to
generate
microsoft was not in a position to do
this so this is this is them actively
seeking out this uh this sort of
back-end stuff in order to be prepared
for these type of purchases and you
speak about the relationship they've had
with netflix for the longest time
so again sometimes we don't like to we
like to think that these
these deals come together in a very
serious
way
i'm not saying it i'm not saying it's
not above board i'm just saying that
conversations probably happen with
companies about how can we figure out
ways to work together in the future
whether that be partnered up or whether
that be you know being absorbed into one
or whatever the case may be to make x y
and z for future scenarios viable right
and this absolutely points to this is a
long-term goal this is how we get to it
because before then microsoft
in
if they didn't have those aspirations in
place there'd be no reason for them to
go out and purchase xander they really
wouldn't because
their advertising would be limited to to
their you know whatever being and
whatever whatever they're doing
that's it
so and you know they kind of be
advertising sort of uh to like when you
say when you're speaking to the chorus
or whatever it it is that so
to me this is this has ramifications
across the board so i can see where
attic is like people jumping the gun and
oh my god xbox is gonna benefit so much
from this
that could definitely happen because the
fact of the matter is that game pass
pull
adding more value to game pass where at
the same time we still haven't heard
about any prices going up yet so
but even if it does go up five dollars
more at the premium tier the ultimate
tier to add netflix to it i'll play
that would be interesting that would be
that would be super interesting yeah
that would probably be the um
the the supported tier the ad supporter
one you know it's crazy that i want to
go on like a little small rant how is it
called
that we can't adjust the volume on zoom
but i can turn into this
[Music]
wow
they're gonna follow you to a cave and
take out your treasure
anyway moving on but uh yeah one to
watch we'll see what's going on we'll
get these super chats get on to the next
time hold on one second
so yes i have
albino king
wow
she's for the streets
wow
there we go
ten dollars if you chat imagine like
game pass ultimate has ea you have a
bundle of netflix disney plus and game
pass ultimate save for 30 a month crazy
value for consumers as far as purchasing
it's a public company remember the
twitter deal exactly so there's a lot
more involved when you're purchasing a
company that's public already right so
so it can happen but there is a
there's a lot that goes into that so
again a partnership
makes more sense but again if the the
price is right and if if you know
netflix is willing to sort of
willing to dissolve all of its shares
and
allowed itself to be absorbed
things could be very very interesting
shout out to slow-mo in the chat for
saying
what's the problem this is how i've
always seen an addict
young fox
that's it we'll call it super chats so
we go set up this is addict's time we're
going to set you up
i'll set you up yeah look look okay so
we have finally playstation stars which
playstation has something similar to
this in the in the past i can't with
this box bro
[Laughter]
why you got an issue with me i ain't
feeling you with this [ __ ] you know you
don't like me as my true self my true
self
[Music]
playstation has introduced something
called playstation stars into the mix
now playstation stars is pretty much
like uh microsoft rewards uh they there
was a version of this
he identifies as a fox down deal with it
i'm sorry continue he's
shout out to uh playstation vice
president um uh grace chen of network
advertising loyalty and licensed
merchandise today sony is revealing this
was uh forgot what date it was uh july
july 14th um they're pleased to reveal
uh playstation stars brand new loyalty
program that celebrates you the player
for being on its ever growing gaming
journey with us playstation stars will
be free to join when it launches later
this year once you become a member you
will earn rewards by completing a
variety of campaigns and activities a
monthly check-in campaign simply
requires you to play any game to receive
a reward while other campaigns require
you to win tournaments earn specific
trophies or even be the first player to
platinum a blockbuster title in your
local time zone there's only one person
you're ridiculous all playstation star
members
will have opportunities to earn loyalty
points points can be redeemed in a
catalog that may include psn wallet
funds and select playstation store
products as an additional benefit
playstation plus members enrolled in
playstation stars automatically earn
points for purchases on playstation
store and the last thing they say is
also part of playstation stars we're
unveiling a new type of reward called
digital collectibles and i think that's
what started the controversy at first it
was like yo what's that and that's why
that's why attic is a fox okay because
the fear was that yo is this nft sony
but
to sony's defense they've come right out
and said that this is not nft's
according to playstation they've said
this is another
name the emoji
[Laughter]
they said you can't trade them or sell
them it's not leveraging any blockchain
technologies and definitely not nft so
sony has gotten in front of this too
with the washington post in reference to
that and that's what uh chen said but
nft i mean basically
lord fox addict collect the books
nft that's why they're
we we love the nfts here lord carl
it's not nfc's attic it is not see lord
cognito i have bought my own eyeliner
from the 20s like you can see this tree
right here that's my tree you got that
on playstation stars
regular nfts we got like a generic
island on the other hand
for the playstation
ones wow
what do you want to discuss about this
topic this is your topic sir what do you
want us to i just think that it's um it
is cool that you know we're starting to
finally get more uh these kind of
programs on all platforms uh i do know
that like i said there was something
similar to this on playstation a while
back but
it didn't look like they supported it a
lot but now that they've rebranded it
hopefully they'll support it a lot more
so i'm very curious where this goes like
do you guys uh but i do feel like this
is another example of uh you know sony
catching up to where microsoft is in
other aspects of the gaming industry
like i said they had something like this
but if they had it to this degree i
don't feel like they would need it now
it's funny as hell
careful
all right so yeah what do you think
south about uh playstation star is the
program
you know lord lord uh playstation star
himself says uh you know what he what's
our opinion
so
i mean yeah i mean this is great because
you know as you
as the amount of people that purchase
games digitally continues to increase
um the incentives for sort of rewards
just haven't been there right uh on the
xbox side they've managed to figure that
out with the microsoft rewards that you
know
anything from like using bing to search
for stuff or answering like little
questions and stuff a little uh sort of
quizzes and things like that to get you
points
um
to purchasing games i think that used to
be a thing i don't know if that is a
thing anymore with digital purchases
where they do give you credit for that
um and even on the like on the nintendo
side nintendo the eshop you know every
per every time you purchase something
digitally or physically yeah you earn
gold coins right you're you're in gold
coins and you own silver coins like the
silver stuff or the platinum stuff it
might be it allows you to buy like nft
like sort of digital project products
but you know it's like calendars or jpeg
files or whatever
um but it also allows you to buy stuff
uh physical stuff in their store if you
collect enough of it but the gold coins
convert directly to
cash in the e-shop
so
it was time i know attic mentioned i
don't remember this on the playstation
side where it used to they used to have
something like that i know they had it
but maybe it wasn't directly associated
with games it was more like a sony thing
right so it doesn't it's not necessarily
for everyone but it's about time they
had something like this on the gaming
side because again
when you see people it's hard to do it
for physical games because i know even
on the eshop stuff on the nintendo stuff
you buy up you a physical game and once
you put it into your system it allows
you it'll say this game is worth
whatever 300 points or whatever coins or
whatever
but after that's done it like if you
resell that game obviously it's not
going to be able to work but again
there's work that goes into half to
preventing that from happening right
so it's more of a digital centric thing
so for them to finally sort of be like
hey we got to get people rewards for
engaging in our ecosystem whether they
be physical or these dumb jpegs or
whatever things and the things that you
in-game sort of stuff that you might be
able to purchase you know with loot box
sort of stuff whatever
i know they're figuring it out but at
the core of it give me
give me money so i can spend
less in your digital shops and i'll be
happy um and i think you know it feels
like they're working towards that so
good on them again again imitation is
the the sincere form of flattery and
obviously it's been working on other
platforms get it done uh steam he was
looking at you yeah
word bro like they're you know i don't i
don't need any cards or whatever you're
giving me or some fake points that don't
get me anything
you know i understand steam sales are
nice but you know get give me some give
me a little something back and for the
record they said that the playstation
star reward details that playstation
plus subscribers will earn additional
points to spend on the playstation store
redeemable stand-alone games dlc
collectibles and more in the future
their monthly check-in and the unique
special reward for the first player to
get a platinum in their region okay
you know we're gamers we like everything
to be gamified so game of five making
money that works no doubt lord king play
style you a playstation star let's go
they're not even a playstation star
you know when you heard it you was like
yeah sony don't ever give you anything
for free what's the catch
what's the catch with this dude well
first catch that i heard was uh they're
gonna give the first person in the
region a platinum and they get a reward
all right so you get a dollar back and
you got a platinum in your region so we
only have to deal with the 13 regions we
do have
13 individuals at a dollar good that's
1.2 points all right good that we could
we could do that that's good that's a
good that's a go we don't lose anything
there
all right so
you better be the first dude to plat
them in your area
and i hope they show you who platinum
then area so you could turn your anger
to that guy he's not my buck all right
tony from wisconsin yeah yeah whatever
um
how grindy is the reward
because i'm looking at gran turismo and
you know you could get the content in
there but you had to do like 500 hours
to get a bumper sticker for uh
what was that the ferrari spider
so
i yo i don't trust them never did i
won't trust them with my information so
you're gonna get to tear
how how how soon before they introduce
the season pass to the reward oh my god
here we go you're gonna have to purchase
it and you're gonna see a season pass
you have to grind in order to get a skin
of cradles that you can't trade with
your friend how how can sony nft the nft
situation without making them real nfts
we're not part of the blockchain guys so
everything you get here you don't even
own it uh
you we're gonna have you grind for it
and it's gonna be yours it's only gonna
be yours in this corner until we say not
and we remove it from your store without
telling you you have no access to it um
these are the same dudes last week that
took movies out of this situation i
don't trust them to do right by any
gamer so yeah it's nice that they can
yell out reward program and see you next
year when at the end of the year we'll
tell you more about what you're gonna
get
you're gonna get robbed and you gotta
get wrong what they doing is trying to
cultivate some good feeling in you for
later when they actually do let the
other shoe drop and you realize
you're not getting anything special from
them because sony never gives back
anything so no i've never gotten
anything on my sony playstation and
hopefully i am surprisingly wrong about
this yes but i think i'm going to be 100
right that it's going to come with some
form of season pass that you got to buy
to get started
so no
look i mean you know
i don't have a problem with it you know
as far as the um the loyalty stuff i do
think there is something else maybe
cooking and i want to shout out um from
sacramento uh dustin fuhrman they they
had they talked about it and one thing
that
i think we're seeing some inklings of
when you talk about this was the digital
collectibles and it says um
collectibles will be the versus their
portfolio products and franchise did
digital represent representation of
things that playstation fans enjoy
including figurines of beloved and
iconic characters from games and other
forms of entertainment as well as
cherished devices that tap into sony's
history of innovation you know one thing
that we're hearing rumblings of is the
return of playstation home
remember yeah we need that from ps3 era
and you know it was a good documentary
showing that recently but
yeah like i think that with psvr 2 you
know coming out is on the horizon with
that and obviously you know in the vr
space obviously the whole team you know
like there's a you can come to my
virtual house so to speak right
if i have these little setups that i've
earned in game it kind of personalizes
and stuff like that so be on the lookout
let's see if they you know do something
like that and really you know kind of
they have this storied history of
characters and franchises and things
like that i could see that i would love
that that would be cool oh that would be
cool to bring back that playstation home
i thought that was so good on the
playstation 3.
when it disappeared
i was like wow you had the makings of
something that kept me inside your
environment yeah ecosystem like yo you
know could you imagine you sitting in
your house and the dude knocks at your
door that's a friend that's coming over
into your party and then when he does
come into your house he's in your party
chat yeah i mean yeah that was that was
the message
i was just about to say
they were literally the metaverse before
the metaverse in anyway because like i
said that concept was so ambitious for
ps3 and again i got to send you a
documentary i forgot the gentleman who
did it talking about like what it took
to get that off the ground get that
going the avatar system the world the
social spaces and you know it took a lot
out of them you know what i'm saying
long term and then i'll say it went away
but it'll be interesting if it comes
back because again where will you see
these digital collectibles at right
where yeah
yeah it's a potential thing and i'm very
curious about that other than that
rewards you know look game pass does it
excellent right now i love you go in
there just launch a game pass game or
play this game do that you see the
points pop up then you convert that
right into money microsoft points flip
that and get you know games back you
know to purchase later those points you
keep playing if you play games though
choices accumulate they accumulate yeah
bro i've so i've funded many future
purchases because i'm just playing
naraka bladepoint right now and every
day i log in it's free it's to get a
ballpoint power point so if they have
something like that yeah go for it like
reward the bass that plays your games
and
let's see where they go at so that's
where i'm at with it just
very curious about the the vr aspect of
the home i want to know if they pray
that that would be cool so keep your eye
on that but that's all i got anything
else before we move there goes king
oh yeah here we go super chats first of
all
hold on a second let's see what we got
here yeah let me see
we got
well uh necromancer sale five dollar
super chat what are the other threes iop
lords nft animals
i'm i'm a gorilla mm-hmm
i don't think i missed anything else
hold on a second
yeah that the last one i got was hard to
knee before that i don't see anything
else so we should be good
so again this is kings topic uh set this
thing up
yeah latest ps5 uh firmware shout out
segment next on rapport causing vr
flickering and burning issues
um looks like
it's been a few months vrr support on
ps5 seems like some firmware of ps5 is
causing flickering and burning issues on
some displays with vrr enabled and then
apparently there's a person who has
screens and footage of marvel spider-man
and ratchet and click having some issues
restarting the games did not seem to fix
the issue the issue can be found on um
also be found on sony screens as of now
sony has not officially acknowledged the
issues so if you're encountering a
problem it's recommended that you keep
vrr disabled
and um yeah keep in keep reminders sony
has mentioned that not all games will
automatically support vrr developers
will have to optimize the games for us
so this is king's topic
king
um they clearly wanted to bring this to
our attention to the realm he felt the
desire to educate us on what's happening
in the sony ecosystem so uh yeah king
the floor is yours what you want to talk
about shout out to the the great team at
microsoft the engineers the
extraordinaires shout out to the great
jason reynolds and squad
for engineering engineering such a
stable box
with with
such such beautiful words like uh
prr and um
velocity architecture and
smart delivery and stuff that is baked
in from a silicon level
stuff that
is done
with foresight and and where technology
is going to engineer a box that is not
fluctuating in between
should we use speed or should we use
power captain
your ship
has a choice and the choice is stability
now
over at the playstation shout out to
mark cerny
for having a different philosophy
his philosophy is
why the hell do i need speed if today i
need power uh
but today i don't need that much power i
need speed so you have a juggling
unstable box
and
shout out to vrr
for them implementing it after the fact
thinking it's just oh it's a flick of
the switch it's a flick all right it's a
flick your tv is flickering and causing
burning listen everyone
go out now
notice
more burning happens
put this next to your box oh my god
secure your home
i'm telling you right now it's an
unstable hot box
there's just more signs to come the
apocalypse is here fellas
could you imagine you playing spider-man
and then you go to get a drink and you
come back your spider-man is still stuck
to the wall on your television as you
still swinging could you imagine you
played ratchet and clay with the fast
ssd and you pull the world to you and it
flickers twice and ratchet is still
there and you look good you imagine you
just paid five grand for your lg and you
thought you was it cause you had that
beautiful old led experience
suffering from burning well
here sir
cool that playstation down
do not allow that playstation to ruin
your gaming experience please
go right now to the switch and turn the
rr off let's say televisions across
america that's not allowed
to realize this is a pandemic this
this is
talent amount to the red ring of death
oh my god
you can control it so if you if you
thought you were getting vrr
no sir you were getting the real visual
burning
so are you implying that this is a
epidemic this is a widespread issue that
you are so concerned with the
playstation community this this is
terrible you weren't able to switch the
cause burning who the hell has a burden
switch in the box like why would you put
that switch in first of all who tried
out the vrr before they okay this
you just said 9 yards and nobody's gonna
use it and they actually did
oh my god this guy
i can't wear himself
yeah so that's king of winning
on the vrr situation uh clearly king
thinks this is a secret epidemic that is
rampant throughout the community and he
wants to give you the best protections
you possibly could have to kind of
protect yourself from this situation and
that yeah there you have it
oh my god
yeah so um
that's all i had
i don't have much to add to this um i
don't experience this
i uh have vrr i have put on
your playstation i have vr on my
playstation and i have nothing
turn it off right now i know exactly how
much you pay for your tv and turn it off
you're ridiculous
geek squad don't support
addict uh
if you have any feelings on the uh vrr
situation that
gets talked
yes
smart man
this is this is yo this is the bundle
that they tell you it's called an
anti-burn-in bundle
[Laughter]
with every playstation you get a ratchet
and clay and a fire extinguisher
it's the anti-burning
please stop them now it's an epidemic
you you too can save a television at the
playstation
just don't enable vr all you know
i don't know how he finds these things
like listen find this whole manner of
seo scraping for me to find anything
when we submit the topics for the show
i'll be like yo i don't find this
this research and development team
what's going on with sodium i'm going to
tell you right now my goings in the
street my tree is wild crazy i'm here
every week to give you hayachi face
you gonna realize listen i i just saved
a billion tvs in the world right now
because apparently this is the most
sought after piece of tech in the world
and it's gonna sell billions but when
you get it in the house please buy the
defense over here
but reducement kit please buy the heat
we do keep reducement
when you purchase it but when you when
you set it up
there's gonna be a button that says vrr
say no
the vrr save your toys
thank you for your service for the
community thank you for all you do for
us king if it wasn't for you we would
not know these things i had to bring
this topic up on god i did not want
another sad man or woman across america
or child could you imagine a child and
you don't know why spider-man is still
on your screen after you turned it off
after you started watching a puppy
patrol and you realize
that
clink is inside puppy patrol and he's
still doing the same pull jerk move you
like pause oh my god
please let's let's let's stop the
burning across america solve any uh last
minutes before
let me see if we got any more hold on a
second
i think we're good
all right i don't think we're good
i don't think the chat had anything else
to say on this yes yes thank you
good thing i don't plan to turn that
playstation on that vrr is rapping
with the acquisition of bungie now
finalized by sony which outcome do you
think will happen first during their
tenure as a playstation studio the
choices are a bungie completes and
releases one of the 10 rumored live
service games for sony first
b
destiny 3 will release first
or c i don't care we all know how bunzie
does in relationships she will find a
way to be single once again as a student
those are the choices please rock that
when it hits the lords of gaming dot net
vocal to the chats with everybody here
being super messy and ridiculous today
absolutely hilarious lord attic let's
start with you where can the people find
you what you got going on sir
finally on youtube
at a gaming ad find me on twitter
lordaddictiop
uh this wednesday i will be having a
special guest on the attic show so
definitely uh be tuned into that i'm not
gonna tell you guys yet but uh you know
we'll we'll see how it is it's gonna be
a fun show i appreciate it coming up we
had up like
750 people in the chat uh we will be i'm
going to go ahead and say uh eventually
we will be doing have a um
another giveaway uh related to other
things that we have but uh going but we
need more clarification on that so be
looking out for that we do want to give
to the community back we have been
laying down a little bit in terms of
those and we want to pick that up a
little bit absolutely uh i do appreciate
everyone for uh you know coming through
i'm gonna once the podcast is over i'm
gonna try that redirect feature i've
never tried it i'm gonna try it yeah
let's give it a shot so hopefully you
guys will like uh my my friend over the
stream of call of duty warzone okay uh
but i don't know if it's gonna work so
it might not do anything so
never done it man
apparently we have
i did look up so i i think the gift
memberships is only for certain people
right now like they're in the middle of
the beta testing got it that's that's
right i've never seen it that's why i
didn't know it would have gone up but i
appreciate it for coming through we'll
see you next week uh we'll also be doing
more of those community streams yeah
that was fun we got to do this yeah at
least once a month just the laws that
was so much fun just gay like got a game
together more a lot of a lot of podcasts
and i feel you know the gaming is
missing right and we talk about these
topics we get it and we have fun and
king definitely has fun you know well
the biggest issue is is is timing yeah
the schedule
it really is yeah
like i said if we pick one saturday a
month right and just we figure out give
something back because that was a lot of
fun i missed playing with y'all
next yeah i notice you're getting all
the choices
we play wrestling next or we play
shredder but you you already had your
double choices now already
second off i'm sorry that i mentioned
the game and it got chose you guys act
like you could have did not you did
wrestling got picked you act like i
wrapped my hands around your neck
actually you know what you know what
wrestling did get picked
what
wrestling ninja turtles got picked off
yeah and ninja turtles got picked yeah
digital
oh here come the day
we got
[Laughter]
he identifies himself as a fox right now
we can't
we can't insult him we can't insult him
he he's a 10 but he
pulling the fox card on us and he can
try to get us cancer
seen have you seen two making star fox
these are my brothers
get this celebrity fox out of here i
mean
he tried to eat that overcooked eddie he
tried to push
go ahead and gift us all 2k because it's
on sale right now
shredders revenge you know what i'm
saying that's right he played that and
showed his retention actually yes sir
i like that i like
what you have going on sir nothing man
just gaming on the damn steam deck
enjoy enjoy my being able to play you
know aaa games is fun again so is it a
wreck is switchgate no longer covered in
hottest ones the switch gang is switch
gang is in the bushes until the first
party release comes that's right okay so
first party first party first party
first part
i mean well never mind let me shut up oh
i will be reviewing a game tomorrow
it'll be up i think it's 8 00 a.m i
don't know okay when the embargo lists
but keep an eye out for some content uh
and it will be up uh hopefully sometime
tomorrow unless something happens
but i appreciate everyone for coming
through no doubt no doubt lord sovereign
as you were saying
yeah so that's it uh just rocking on the
steam deck uh
glad to play yesterday that was fun that
was so much fun
yeah uh yeah no doubt and then stick
around because we have three more we got
three more advanced gg giveaways
i do want to bring up
recently like how is it that the person
that didn't grow up in the platforming
area was platforming better than the
people that grew up in the platforming
area during fall guys you're just a
savant dude like
you have you we have to admit that your
your reflexes are faster than ours
and he been playing that game
since playstation released it i'm okay
with that i'm getting i i'm getting
perked for being young let's go
uh play magician lord and be quiet oh
yeah you gotta get his balls open
he's been playing that game
for unless we send for you we ain't do
that we don't do that don't come first
unless we stand for you i'll send
magician lord joy
turned you back into it we did give you
props for your for your um ninja gaiden
that was good that was good
and i thought i was playing with jordan
and i didn't get a ring so i i really am
disappointed i was promised the premium
experience and i didn't receive such so
again
i'm not i'm not impressed you know so
now you
yeah everybody will do everything and
then i will come back to it right before
this no doubt lord king
which the public service announcements
for the community and uh
all the uh topics so what do you have to
say for yourself sir what do you have
going on you have to save me
i want somebody to clip that and put
that up make sure that that gets out you
know uh for all uh playstation owners
i got you boo that was another thing i
encouraged the chat as much as you could
like share clips of this podcast on you
on twitter man like yeah instagram
twitter do whatever you want share clips
if you think of parts funny use the the
the clip feature on youtube but share it
on twitter
yeah get that out there because people
need to know about what vrr is doing to
our gaming community
it's dividing
us you know we got to make that a
patreon tier like
like he sets up a commercial about what
vr's doing
but you can find me on twitter king
david otw
same uh
hashtag uh on my gamer tag on xbox and
on my playstation whenever a game
actually comes out that i can actually
play and care about
which hopefully is god of war which is
next year um
that's xbox 360 level one whenever i
decide to go over there and
actually fight with sony for why i don't
have access to my account right now i
think they're being petty with the god
and i have to fight back but combat talk
with the king saturdays at 10 p.m
i want to thank everybody that came out
and uh i told you
first uh 1k people free drinks on me we
was drinking uh hennessy and bailey's
yesterday
definitely a dope situation we got a
chance to see ryan garcia knock out for
tuna in the sixth round he uh
caught him with a couple of good body
shots and that one two three combination
i think ryan garcia
is the second coming of
golden boy um
oscar de la hoya
um he's he's he's gonna be but what i
want his uh i want his kihones to drop i
want him to
have the same respectability of oscar de
la hoya oscar de la hoya for each and
every last person that had a name in his
generation coming up and and and moving
forward i respect oscar de la hoya for
all his boxing skills and his choices of
fights win lose a draw the man always
got up and went in someplace else and
got another fight which was a big fight
he fought pacquiao yeah he fought floyd
he fought he fought everybody that
mattered even the biggest stronger
bernard hopkins uh and sugar shane he
has classic battles uh you know me and
cog and sovereign has huge stories when
it comes to that and i think ryan garcia
can be that dude
and he's with the right person
he's the second coming he just gotta he
just got to let it go but um catch me
with combat talk saturday is 10 p.m i do
appreciate everybody that showed up and
i'm about to be a little bit more messy
on twitter
oh oh oh well
no no i'm always never behaving
i'm 97 well as long as it ain't beefing
with me i'm good because i'm tired of
beef with you
now dude yo dudes add me to crocs
me and you in this game no i go for a
shout out to you
shout out to james that was the funniest
joy i am not going that far
and they look like they had ilp
wifey i showed wifey
she looked at her she said how the hell
they did that that's how they got y'all
with the shirts on i was like first of
all that's not a second one that's not
iop shirts i said but they look damn did
look close it didn't look inside the
james i was dying to give you always
having fun and all that good stuff but
yeah look great show salute everybody
that pulled up a lot of love a lot of
jokes a lot of fun but uh we got more
things planned um some good guests some
good secret stuff going on cooking
events things heating up and we
definitely doing more stuff with the
community as well as some giveaways
giving back and stuff you got some
speaking of giving back we got some
things to
yeah okay so powder yeah we got some
more powder
we got three more giveaways of that
powder so remember
i'll get at you in dms or on your emails
um so yes okay so our fourth overall
advanced gg giveaway goes to
karma funk shout out to you karma funk
[ __ ] let's go get that starter pack
advanced gg you're gonna get hooked up
you know what i'm saying make sure how
they gonna contact you so i'll make sure
if
i'm gonna hit you in your emails because
the emails are here as part of your your
patreon stuff i'm going to look up your
names and if the names are similar it'll
come up on twitter
i said that's going to be the hard thing
yeah it's going to be
because there's no contact information
yeah
so that's the tough part what are your
favorite flavors of the powder um for
focus the one that um addy got that sour
sour watermelon allen addict put it up
real quick you know what i'm saying
that's how i wanted minimally if you
have it so you can see the people can
see it you still got it next to you is
that sour
addicts acting like you don't hear what
i'm talking about well no i i don't hear
you sorry yeah
yeah you got that they said what's the
flavors that we liked i said that sour
the one that you got for focus yeah i
like that show can you show the people
that sour right quick yeah let me hold
on let me play talk while you're talking
you got it up hello hello hello testing
guys
there you go there you go that's that
that's what about number one or on the
focus on the energy that's fox face
energy yes on the energy that birthday
cake or that dream tea
and then for the hydration right now
that lemonade is for the people like i
said who don't want caffeine don't want
sugar they don't want any of that other
stuff that focuses energy does this is
the not caffeine and no no sugar
substitute so you can do that so anyway
two more giveaways let's go fcg the
building powder let's go
all right so our fifth overall advanced
gg giveaway goes to
[Music]
gaming forte
yeah we missed forte man we got to get
him back he's been having talked to him
too too much and yo listen you're out
you're out there doing them long hours
again stop bro you know you need a
little focus
he has to get all those delay orders
ready oh damn
no doubt
okay and our final advanced gg giveaway
goes to
[Music]
nope gotta re-roll that word
somebody named ander okay
we definitely gotta be roll at gotta
remove that
sorry
all right once again
our final uh advanced gg giveaway goes
to
suede cookies
trying to get one over yeah the lords
wanted
the lord one of the kids cookies we got
the brownies for you baby
suede cookies i like i like that i like
that get that advantage again tell the
people right quick you know what i'm
saying
exactly i will be hitting you up with a
link to do and with the instructions
exactly what to do like you do have to
sign up for an account with advanced gg
but again this first it'll give you all
the information to get your free stuff
up front
um yeah thank you thank you for being
members no doubt shout out to the
members again for non-members make sure
you go to advancedg.com 20
off through monday go get that you know
what i'm saying and you get a little
discount and all that but that's all we
got anything else before we wrap up out
of here lords nope we good to go
everybody enjoy yours
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you